[Music]
I'm the one
uh third on all strikeouts uh all-time
strikeout leader first pitcher ever to
start a season in 20 uh 2001 with 20 and
one no one's ever done that before MVP
five strikeout titles 354 wins I can
give you a bunch of different stats on
what he's done one time he pitched game
four of the 2000 ALCS game uh and then
right afterwards game two of the World
Series logging in 17 shutout Innings and
let only three hits in those 17 Innings
with 24 strikeouts and an expert when it
comes down to movies Give It Up to Roger
Clemens how you doing man doing good
guys I need you as my agent let's go I
didn't know some of those right there
that's pretty good let's be clear Roger
is more than just a baseball player yes
okay so we had with you Antonio Brown
wanted us to make sure that the audience
knew you're not from Liberty City you're
more than a baseball player you family
man you have a family your kids uh is it
three out of four is it uh all four boys
start with the letter k it started with
Kobe I punched out 20 and 86 and uh he
was on his way to be born and uh so
instead of with the c i we threw the K
in there and we kept trying for a girl
so but the K's kept coming so uh just
like her career the case kept coming
yeah just it's like that four boys all
start with k four boys but is it let me
get it Kobe Cody Corey and uh Casey man
it's pretty good it's a tongue twister
but that's pretty good if you guys were
gonna have a girl did you know what the
name was going to be with the K Carissa
Carissa yeah I almost adopted a gal a
little a little one um man she was
tugging in my heart we were at a a deal
an outing where some uh kids were
getting placed with different homes and
and uh it was close I mean I was pulling
at my heartstrings for sure Roger out of
the out of your four boys how many made
it into the major leagues I know we just
talked about three of them yeah three of
the four all played uh professionally
um number two actually grad he's a chef
and in real estate and uh he played a
little football had his kneecaps reset
so I said can we try something different
you know and uh but yeah I I you know I
I always played the dad role I tell
everybody that uh until you know Casey
my number three child Casey just retired
from the Blue Jays and uh
he was a big reason why I got hooked up
to come down and get to do this with you
guys and
um the youngest one Cody is a second
baseman can play multiple positions he's
he's with the Philadelphia Phillies just
was traded this off season from the
Detroit Tigers so but uh I love it that
they play
um uh uh you know the game that we all
love and
um you know it's life lessons teaches
along teaching them to get along but
like I told them I'm glad that they were
all Americans at the University of Texas
I'm more proud that they graduated from
McCombs business school and a quick
shout out when I say that Red McCombs
just passed away not too long ago red
was a
a pillar uh around Austin at the
University of Texas and Red McCombs and
it's it's a very very uh respected uh
School uh uh yeah my wife and I we lived
in Plano for five years and my wife's
from Houston I mean she we met in LA but
we lived in Dallas for five years and uh
yeah I mean when you mentioned that
school uh salute respect at the highest
level may he rest in peace was Red
McCombs also the owner of the Minnesota
Vikings
uh that is a great question you pull
that up is it the same Red McCombs I'm
thinking of
type in Vikings to see if that comes up
there you go yeah no he was yeah I heard
that name for years because my family's
from Minnesota yeah good call right
there hey so so but you know what's one
of the things I saw which was kind of
cool can you pull up the clip I think
it's Cody pitching oh yeah did you see
that one right there he's pitching if
you see this one here which is sick uh
he's pitching against shohei Otani and
Watch What Happens here it's a really
neat thing to see watch this okay to the
story that I just learned Cody Clements
who struck out shohei Otani last night
he's like time time let me throw in the
ball I want to get it authenticated so
here we go there's an authenticator
[Music]
would sign the baseball how sick is that
when you see that what do you think
about like did he call you afterwards
dad you won't believe it what was the
reaction like yeah so there's a there's
a lot of moving parts to this in the
video first of all he's throwing about
uh 65 miles an hour and it's called an
air cutter when we play catch in the gym
at home he was messing around with it
you grab the ball without any seams and
if you throw at the right speed it
almost acts like a a tight slider and uh
so he threw a back door on him and well
first of all he's he he only he pitched
in high school he's pretty good in high
school and I told his manager at time AJ
hinch that don't tell him or he'll have
you out there so anytime he's pitching
you know uh it's not a good thing that
means the team's getting blown now so
what's his position second base gotcha
so he's not even a pitcher he doesn't
pitch he he played uh he can play a
little first little third for match-up
problems even left field
but anyway so he's in a blowout which uh
happened way too many times with the
Tigers last year and uh he threw the air
cutter it came back over the corner he
strikes him out and he reacted and
that's when he called me he goes man I
didn't even know I pumped my fist out I
was fired up I said no that's that's
great I said you know that's what makes
it fun for everybody to watch and it's
really cool for you to do it dad never
struck this guy out you know so that you
know and uh and then he had the mindset
to call time and throw the ball out of
play and then he asked me hey you think
I sent this guy will sign this he goes I
said absolutely send it over I knew a
few of the Angel Players and uh but yeah
that was that was the scenario you know
and again you know it's a bad thing when
it was the highlight of the Tiger's uh
season by the way what do you think
about him as a hitter as a player
pitcher and hitter yeah you know guys I
I play the dad role again I um you know
the boys always tease me when I start
getting into hitting uh the philosophy
or whatever and if they ask me a
question they're just like pops what do
you know about hitting you were just a
great Bonner that's all you could do you
know and uh so uh I kind of just uh and
let's ask me a pointy question same
thing with their teammates their veteran
teammates I'll give them a I'll give
them an answer you'll see me at games
I'm kind of locked in on what's going on
because I'm trying to watch the pitchers
Tendencies I really focus on the catcher
too because now with this uh pitch clock
um it's you know the catcher is really
going to be the quarterback if you will
and The Catcher in the major leagues
second manager anyway and so I'm
watching Tendencies you know he might
get a home run or something like that
and and I don't I don't even you know
forget app and the camera will be on me
and they're like oh you know he's locked
in or whatever but
um yeah when I'm there I'm just watching
uh everything that's going on I was like
that I obviously was a student in the
game when I was 21 years old coming out
of the University of Texas
and um uh I mean just the other day I I
told the guys I back in the early 80s I
kept my hitters on three by five index
cards then it went to my Blackberry then
it went to my iPhone to the point where
I tell my pitching coach in our meetings
before
the playoffs are a World Series game
we're going over hitters I'm over there
I'm not texting my friends to come to
the game I'm actually logging stuff that
I know I also kept a book on the umpires
you know I wanted to know that when an
Umpire was at this game that uh you know
it might be a home game for him and he's
left eight tickets he wants to look good
and you know he might come out to the
mound and it was Derwood whoever say hey
how's you know you know how's Jennifer
doing you know how's the family and
thanks Rock for asking he runs back down
you might get that boy you know that
borderline call and it brings a personal
element into it but
um so all those things matters you're
keeping notes on each player the Umpire
coaches like you're just constantly
keeping notes absolutely absolutely I'm
I'm I'm I'm looking at what I'm doing
and then obviously on on a game day when
you're going out there you're going out
there to see how you know how you feel I
might not have 98 miles an hour that day
my shoulder I might be a little
underwater as they say and uh but I was
a power our pitcher I wasn't a thrower I
don't throw I pitch and I was forwarded
the luxury obviously being in Texas and
getting to know Nolan Ryan and watch
Nolan never teammates but for I think
three months in Boston during a playoff
run we signed Tom Seaver and siever's
the ultimate power pitcher I mean I'm
watching a guy you know I pitched till I
was 45 but at that time I was probably
23 years of age in Boston and I'm
watching a 40 plus year old man out
there
I can hear him grunting in the third
fourth inning and he's sitting at about
90 miles an hour and I'm like um okay
and then he got second and third the
game was on the line boom he popped
popped one in there about 94 for a
strikeout I was like ah okay he's got a
little left in the tank here so it was
great and even watching him was one
thing but having the opportunity to just
to sit and keep my mouth shut and learn
from you know just just hear what he had
to say
um did a radio show way back when with
Don Drysdale I mean we can go on and on
guys I mean it's I I appreciate the uh
the the guys that played before me
because they were helped me make the
living that I was able to make
I want to see one of my favorites here
in a couple hours when I leave you guys
Reggie Jackson
October I'm gonna be with him this
afternoon and he he I tell the story
famously that he was the guy I wanted to
face I wanted to get the big league as
fast as I could I think I pitched 12
games in the miners
and then my second or third start in the
majors I got to face Reggie and he was a
California Angel it was it was a blast I
mean uh you know I almost couldn't make
eye contact you know I couldn't make eye
contact with him when he came to the
plate and um but uh yeah I mean it was
it was it was fun facing him and and
just the the the guys that over 24 years
I was able to face the these name
growing up who was your guy uh when
you're like you talked about Don
Drysdale Nolan Ryan yeah probably uh
probably Nolan and Seaver were the guys
Reggie was uh where Reggie was one for
sure
um you know but I faced the Don Baylor's
Dave kingmans luczinski the bull you
know all these guys all the way through
the Albert Pujols is you know I think
Albert called me I know Kirby Puckett
called me heat I think Albert called but
he'd say you know he would always give
me one good pitch to hit and if I missed
it or fouled it off he you know I got
you and uh but those are good battles I
mean you know I I talked about in the
clubhouse uh the other day to the
players you know I faced a Cal Ripken
probably even though Cal was my
shortstop in multiple All-Star games I
face Cal Ripken um you know say a 120
times so when the game's on the line at
60 feet 6 inches he's got like eight
different batting stances you know where
he holds his badly playing the piano or
playing the flute or whatever they call
he's doing he's seen everything I can
throw at him including the kitchen sink
you know so it's really a a game within
a game of how I'm gonna try and get him
out and do things like that so I try and
I try and tell the younger players about
that it's changed a little bit we got
the pitch clock strike zone now they
pinch you East and West you get North
and South a little better which I which
I would like because I like featuring
the ball high in the zone and then
throwing my split finger down to jog
your eye level
um so um you know just great questions
from uh a lot of the pitchers so this
this new pitch count or this uh how long
it takes to throw it back yeah pitch
clock sorry about that so this pitch
clock is this the first season they're
implementing that yes guys the minor
league guys have experienced it but yeah
so I kind of want to process that like
where you're at with this thing because
you know
baseball you know America's past time
the legacy of baseball past time using
that word intentionally these days the
biggest sport in America is football
basketball kind of has the biggest icons
if you will LeBron Steph Giannis
you know baseball is all about tradition
you know growing up I was all about
baseball that was all I was at you know
honoring the legacy of the past Babe
Ruth Mickey Mantle everything Ty Cobb
how much do you think this pitch clock
is gonna change the game and not honor
the past time that was baseball yeah
there's a lot there's a lot to it I mean
even when you when you talk about the
pitch clocks you talk about the uh
analytics and I'm kind of in the middle
of ground there I'm not in the high end
of it or you know push it to the side
it's going to change a little again now
because you can't play you can't do the
shift so my kid is playing second his
feet his feet both feet have to be on
the dirt
um you can't be playing you know having
four outfielders or having a second
baseman play just about right field
um Pitch clock the main thing and that
uh again I preached it to two teams when
I leave here again I'm gonna tomorrow
I'm gonna talk to Houston and uh the
main focal point will be I think it's a
focus thing now because you're speeding
up and it's going to turn a pitcher into
a thrower because all you're going to do
is look at the catcher get the sign real
quick and here we go I'm heaving it and
you're going to make a lot of mistakes
in the strike zone or you're going to
throw some pitches without really
uh uh you know being behind that pitch
mentally and focused on where you want
to throw it so I I think it'll make
again there's a couple pictures that are
wearing The Wristband that are calling
their own game I called 90 95 percent of
my game from the mound just with my
looks
um with my catchers had some wonderful
catchers you always give them guys props
over 24 years had some fantastic
catchers that paid attention to detail
and if one of those Sketchers got traded
to another team and we're playing them I
I couldn't they knew they knew my
Cadence and what I was doing with my
eyes and which side of the plate I
wanted to throw the baseball on but uh
again I think the main thing about the
pitch clock is that guys are just going
to start grabbing a ball get a sign and
throw it without understanding how
you're trying to break a hitter down do
you think here's where I'm going with
this Roger
um do you think that this is something
that's inevitable meaning like listen
you gotta evolve that's just kind of how
Sports work hey you gotta adapt with the
times you know and it's a good thing you
know the only thing constant is change
or the other end of the spectrum sign of
the times you look at gen Z these days
or even younger kids you know elementary
school and all that their attention span
is so limited right you know if you
don't get someone's attention in three
seconds five seconds whether it's tick
tock or SnapChat they just can't pay
attention they're not going to sit
through a three and a half hour baseball
game or it's a pitcher's duel and it's
1-0 going into the ninth and they're
just like they want it quick they want
it fast this this sort of instant
gratification there's sort of the good
bad and ugly of this what are your
thoughts again you've got kids in their
20s 30s and you've enough you said you
had grandkids right yeah the grand boy
so you've got a good perspective on Age
and and generations yeah I mean it's
just like you said but with like like
football when I talk to the college
football players I mean coaches they
they gotta let music blare in the
clubhouse now and they got to have
everybody's got a TV in front of their
locker with their swag and their
highlights on it you just got to kind of
roll the roll at the Times a little bit
with these guys
you want to speed up baseball he said
get rid of the walk-up music and
everything else but that's that's it
that's baseball baby you got your walk
up music everybody's dialing and popping
their collar and now you know I I
pitched right through it I mean the
early days in the early days if you hit
a bomb and you flipped your bat oh yeah
do that to Nolan Ryan or Bob Gibson and
see if you're even alive to play the
next game straight up I mean it those I
mean that was you know I'm jumping
around here my my uh Don Drysdale
uh uh uh story was I was 22 years old I
just pitched in Winter Haven I was with
the Red Sox I pitched my three Innings
against the Dodgers were in town
obviously and and big Don Drysdale was
doing his radio show I knew the name I
didn't know him I'd never met him
six foot five our PR guy goes when you
get done icing Don drysdale's outside by
the batting cages like to interview for
his show
so I got there meet him he's a giant of
a man and I mean you're not small yeah
I'm about he he was six you know he had
me buy a full inch and uh and so I go um
uh soft Spoken Man we go through 20
minutes his radio show and he turned his
radio off and then this this this
different voice came out and it's like
let me tell you something kid he goes
I've watched you got a chance in this
game I go thank you Mr Drysdale he goes
you know what my best damn pitch of the
game was kid I go no sir Mr driving now
I'm kind of shaking like the Tin Man a
little Mr Drive oh yeah oh yeah I'm 20.
so I'm kind of I'm kind of got the Tin
Man shaking going on looking at the eyes
here and uh he goes you're my best damn
pitcher the game was son I said no sir
he said it was my uh he said it was my
second knockdown pitch you know why kid
he said because then the hitter knew the
first one an effing mistake and I was
like yes sir Mr dry and I ran out of
there and uh but that that's that's the
old school guys yeah but uh yeah so I
think It's Entertainment you know we've
got the cheerleaders now and the dugouts
you got your walk up songs the guys you
know uh now now I've kind of moved to
um if you don't like the way things are
going play better
um if you don't like the guy flipping
his Bat you know keep the ball out of
the middle of a plate you know you kind
of you're the one that hung it but
um
uh you know like I said I I agree with a
lot of the um the analytics I I get it
but you still have to have an eye and a
heart test you know it was great for me
even in my Advanced age I was in my 40s
and say with the Yankees Mel stodemars
my pitching coach and I would come off
in the seventh inning and I was grunting
out there and you could tell that I was
laboring a little bit and he grabbed me
he's like you know Joe they want to they
want to move to the bullpen and because
it looks like you're emptying your tank
but Mel and I had a little system that
now I go one hitter at a time so I'm
going back out for the eighth knowing
that if this guy gets a base hit or gets
on I'm coming out so my eight warm-up
pitchers are more intense and now I'm
really grinding on it now I get him out
the best closer in the game Mariano
Rivera only has to get four outs now
boom I get enough I get a pop-up now
he's only got you know so that's kind of
how we operated there instead of just
you know dragging somebody out of the
game right away you're in town because
one of your sons is playing he plays for
the Phillies
you said you gave a speech your best
Newt Rodney yeah well they they um the
staff there's about five guys on the
coaching staff including the manager
Robbie Thompson probably the best
hitting coach right now in the major
leagues K long
they have a great staff they have two
front line pitchers the Phillies do and
uh but Robbie once they traded for Cody
he called me and said we're glad to have
Cody if you're coming down this way
would you mind coming in and uh visiting
with the guys for 20 30 minutes so
anytime the guys ask even though I do
you know I I do a lot of work uh with
the Astros foundation and stuff with the
Astros if those guys asked me to be a
part of it I'm all in
um one of my former team Red Sox Yankees
if they asked you know there's a few
young pitchers that are knocking on the
door to the major leagues to visit with
them
with the group of pitchers or one-on-one
I do it I mean I was one of them and uh
like I said I think as you saw me light
up earlier when I had the opportunity to
play with Tom Seaver yeah I mean uh you
become a sponge well I want to talk
about this concept of of being I guess
fatherly advice right I'm not a father
Pat's a father of four he'll be right
back uh but you've kind of mentioned
being a dad or even a grandfather these
days obviously you know the easy
question would be like so you're you
played baseball your kids played
baseball that's you know that's sort of
a layup question but a lot of parents
want to give their kids advice these
days especially around coaching kids
these days the knock on kids is they're
all fat they're lazy they're playing
video games uh so speak to the dads out
there the parents out there that want
their kids to participate in sports
right they they don't have the rocket
Legacy right they're not Papa rocket but
maybe they're athletes or maybe they're
not even athletes but they want to give
their kids advice on what to pursue how
to go at it uh play multiple swords pick
one yeah you know it's more most of the
fathers that are fathers two players
these days are probably didn't play in
the majors like you what are those
conversations like and what advice do
you have for yeah Young Fathers out yeah
there's great question so you got my
mind racing there's just so much
information there that that I try and
pass along I I think I think before I
get into
um any dad advice or Mom advice I mean I
I I think it's great that my oldest son
teaches right now he's had an
opportunity to go coach in the minor
leagues if he wanted to but he's he's
teaching seven-year-olds to college guys
to the pros guy the pro guys come over
and throw to him and uh what's really
cool is he's got some single moms that
are divorced or they're they're the
kid's dad had passed away and he's
watched these kids and he's worked with
them from seven to where they're going
into high school now and they've
improved so much and at my Foundation
um we get wonderful letters about how
you know thank you for what your son's
doing for my kid I knew this Mom I knew
nothing about baseball and he's helped
helped my kid and got him in a team
sport to understand how to work along
and and be a team player and do
something as a group
um so I so I think about that I think
you have to understand where I came from
which people from afar whether wherever
it might be that they look at you and
they and it really pisses me off
sometimes because you know they talk
about athletes having a silver spoon or
something well I wasn't born with this
arm my pops died when I was nine I was
raised by two strong-willed women my
mother my grandmother and just like my
grandmother grabbed me she said if
you're going to be a ditch digger you'd
be the best damn ditch digger in the
country yeah and that's the way she
operated of course she was the same
grandma that took a switch and hit me on
my hamstrings for throwing her picking
her grapes off the Grapevine and
throwing them at cars he she later said
once I made it to the major leagues I
knew that boy is going to be good
because I knew he had an arm on him he
was throwing those grapes off my
Grapevine and passing cars all the time
so you know I watched my mom work three
jobs when I was in high school she was
an accountant by day and I would go with
her in Warehouse buildings and and and
you know watch her clean help her clean
and so I could have a sweet red glove
and a badass pair of cleats you know
excuse me so
yeah you kind of have to start from
there now I wanted my boys to grow up
differently and uh you know again that's
why basically after the first couple
years in Major League Baseball I wanted
to make a generational change and then
after I felt like I had my feet you know
permanently in the ground in the majors
then it was about winning championships
again it's what I learned at the
University of Texas you know you you win
and you know how to win so when I went
to Boston I felt like I was bringing
that winning tradition with me
once I got drafted the dads I tell them
at a 12 year old game years 12 year olds
playing third base and we're sitting in
lawn chairs and even if you were a dad
that was a really good high school or
college player don't forget how fast
that ball gets it looks super slow to us
we're sitting there and we could field
that ball but it gets on that 12 year
old very very fast he's trying to
process that so it's just a it's a
different game our game looks great when
you're sitting in the third fourth row I
would encourage you to come stand in a
batter's box and just watch when I throw
you a you know 95 98 mile an hour
fastball this isn't your local battle
ball where you go put the quarter in the
machine and throws you 10 balls down the
middle
um it's it's just a it's a whole it's a
whole different deal I mean I can't tell
you I I threw a ball in one time a scout
told me I threw a ball in 97 a guy
squared it up it hit me in the shin at
132. I wanted to cry it hurt yeah I
wanted to cry it hurt so bad I mean I
was my molars hurt they came out to the
mound what was was even worse to add to
the just to put a little salt in the
wound as they say the ball ricocheted
off my shin into the the home side
Dugout we were on the road and uh time I
got collected and they wrapped my big
old I had a big old knot swelling up on
my leg uh I looked over the guy standing
on second I said what the hell's what's
he doing they go what's a ground rule
double it hits you it hits you and
bounced it done a guy gets second base I
was like are you kidding me yeah
take so yeah yeah so uh but yeah I try
and tell the parents um
um even if they're playing football
baseball basketball whatever and instead
of hollering out so many commands when
you're on the field or if there's
something they did make a little mental
note and then on the way home maybe turn
the radio off in a car and have a good
little visit about him always tell the
kids take zero towel to hustle that you
have no Talent we have a children's Wing
at home in Houston there's a couple kids
down there with the uh missing a hand
and leg they would love nothing more to
stand in the batter's box take a full
swing
and uh hit a comebacker to the pitcher
and fly down first base and chalk coming
off their you know cleats flying in
they'll never get the opportunity to do
that perspective gratitude that's it so
you know it takes zero talent to hustle
uh you know I I I have no problem from a
eight-year-old to one of my big league
guys making a physical mistake I love
them laying out trying to lay out for a
ball whatever that might be uh obviously
not forgetting how many outs there are
what you're supposed to do there so I
think you know Sports is a great Outlet
I mean I I like that but I also like the
business side of everything too uh we
look at that a lot uh my my boys are you
know definitely into that
um you know they get to be their own guy
and and again I think the uh the biggest
compliment I get it kind of oxymoron but
if you didn't know they were my boys you
wouldn't know it they usually introduce
introduce themselves looking at you and
I hand shaking and say their first name
and um
so I mean that's that's the way I look
at what the dads too I mean I I tell
people they say oh pressure and pressure
and pressure this and pressure that
pitching in game sevens of the World
Series been in six World Series and two
of the losses were the most emotional
but um
uh uh they talk about pressure I tell
people I say you know what pressure is I
said come home with me and
um one of the boys are six seven years
old and you're doing dad's pitch you get
six pitches and I'm trying like hell to
hit that kid's bad and and and five
pitches later I haven't hit his Bat and
one of the moms are up in the stand
screaming at Jesus Christ throw my kid a
strike you're a professional yeah and
I'm like oh my gosh I Gotta Throw you
know I said that's pressure you mean you
gotta you literally did that so you you
would go to uh yeah you would be
pitching to kids so so like Cody I got
pictures of Cody when he was standing
next to me in the dad's Circle you throw
the ball off the kid hits you you got to
run off the field as the dad and they go
crazy and
so I get done pitching to our guys and
I'm walking off the opposing coach comes
said rocket
my kids everybody know will you throw to
our team too I'm like oh my gosh how old
are the kids by the way probably six
seven okay yeah so you just being that
little kid right yeah you're not
supposed to have 12 Tough Enough kid
you're not supposed to have 12 punch
outs in in Dad's [__] you know what I'm
saying I'm not supposed to strike out 12
guys exactly I'm trying to hit the right
competitive nature is going to take over
at some point Sorry kid no I mean that's
you know and and your question was spot
on they'll be you know this off season
or whatever we'll go to a couple of
these games with the grand boys and and
I'll have to call a couple dads or coach
over or go guys yeah my boys and I and
even me I I said do you remember any
trophies that you won up to 12 years old
no I said let's keep your boys healthy
because I do a thing with Dr James
Andrews Andrews Institute Pensacola we
develop a shoulder program for pitchers
and the most famous uh somebody of
course he said he's done more Tommy
John's on 16 year olds and 15 year old
15 year old models yeah he's encouraging
to play other sports set the ball down
maybe play another sport and um but I
just I I preached to the high school
guys you know I'll go there and watch
them throw and the trainer comes over
and Guy pitches like four and eight High
School guys to junior senior in high
school and they'll put the ice on the
kid's elbow with the uh with the wrap
and they'll wrap it the next thing you
know he's sitting in a Dugout for an
hour and you got a nerve in there you
don't want to ice you know if you're a
lot of guys don't ice anymore we we did
it all the time and Ice agrees with me I
got an ice tank there's no way I would
have pitched uh until I was 45 years old
without my body of green to ice
so Pat's got four kids two boys they're
playing sports you know I was uh I
played college football I was a
basketball player as well I I had a
little game but I had the most
contentious relationship with my father
ever okay you got like you talk about
the dad that's on the sidelines yelling
screaming hollering
it's just a it doesn't help B it's
embarrassing right yeah and and see it's
like where what are we doing here we're
in front of everybody it's just not a
good look for the family and I feel like
a lot of fathers
don't know how to handle
you know they're watching their son in
the game right mothers are always going
to be cheering and you know protective
of their kid but the because more than
anything you bond with your kids
a father and son Sports wrestling you
wrestle with your kids all the time it's
different with a mother mother you're
hugging it's kissing it's more
affectionate but for you to be the guy
that's like no take it down a notch like
you're what how do you operate when
you're in the stands even when they were
younger you were you hooting and
hollering and yelling were you just kind
of quiet and stoic yeah I mean how do
you handle it everybody else is doing
the cheering I kind of get stoic I I'm
watching how they're breaking you know
the boys always say dad you know I hit
the Home Run they showed you on the over
the you know in the seats and you
weren't even classic because I was kind
of locked up I'm trying to watch this
picture how he's breaking you down I'm
really focusing on the catcher because I
know he's calling the game against you
so I'm looking for patterns you know but
you know you you clap and react and then
there's some other times where I'm
amazed that this guy even pitched to you
in this situation I mean Cody when he
was at Texas his last year he he put the
team on his back and carried the team
and and again
I I think I could take either one of you
two with me to that Clubhouse and you
guys could cover cover the the analytics
part the sports part a little bit
because like you said you played and and
Pat same thing with you know with the
kids and what he's doing here and and
and then even cover
as what I think is most important even
some of these guys the business part of
it and what happens off the field which
is even more important to me when they
come through that door that they have
their family stuff in order uh we all
have the same we all have the same I
would say I don't call them problems
issues it doesn't matter how much money
you make right you still could have a
girlfriend issue coming in the ballpark
when you gotta you're on the mound in a
in a massive a must-win game for us and
and you gotta as soon as you get out of
your car in a player's parking lot you
got to turn that off because now it's
your second family and this is what
makes the world go around so I can't
tell you how many players that I I
wasn't a babysitter for them but I would
just be like reaffir no that's not
that's not it's not it's not a big deal
right now just focus here get focused on
what you need to do here because once
this game starts stuff's going to be
happening fast and then I need to hear
you tell me that the game is slowed down
that tells me that you've been
practicing perfect you did you're doing
quality work we don't need quantity you
do quality work now if you're having
trouble with your breaking ball your
release point you got a picture of my
pitching coaches or my eyes I said
here's what you whether it been a rookie
pitching coach or a veteran here's my
three hot points I want to feel tall
you know I want to keep my chin down I
don't want to drift and I want to stay
back because they need a big game you're
trying to hurry just like a golfer
golfer swings you try and get up front
you're hitting a slice
so
um it it's uh there's just a handful I
don't even say a handful maybe three or
four hop points whether you're a control
guy 86 a Greg Maddox pinpoint control
two ridiculous control Power make that
ball move like you read about yeah and
uh or or myself and and Greg and I just
did a thing for the Golf Channel we both
said even though we throw almost 10
miles an hour difference we both pitched
off our fastball and we both
um you know he made a great point a big
compliment when they went to interleague
play
um uh he pulled up my starts because he
knew I pitched off my fastball and I
used both sides of the plate and blah
blah blah here's the questions I got
um the game so Anthony Edwards the other
days in the All-Star game and I don't
know if you know Anthony Edwards is
start up a guy in the NBA the guy's a
rock star I think he plays for the
Timberwolves he's on the fireball I mean
he's just an exciting guy to watch and
he said so what do you think about
what's going on with the uh the product
of the NBA and he says you know
um I if there's one thing I could change
with the NBA is I wish Superstars would
play every day and they wouldn't take
these two three days off right
and then I I saw Barkley yesterday uh
he's being interviewed by Stephen A
Smith not yesterday probably two days
ago three days ago and Stephen A Smith's
talking to him about the future of the
NBA the product all this stuff he says
Barkley said the NBA is about to come up
for uh re-signing their new uh TV deal
you know whatever the TV deal they got
to get NFL gets great TV deals but he's
saying hey this new TV deal they did
they do the the company is going to be
asking and saying why the hell are we
doing TV deals people are not watching
season NBA games because players are
taking two three days off and they don't
want to work so to me the product of the
NBA season has become shitty that's my
opinion and I'm a guy that loves the NBA
I don't even watch season anymore
because it's fake to me we got seven
guys averaging 30 points a game annoying
this ain't no real basketball if you're
you know the other day All-Star Game the
worst All-Star game of all time
Sacramento Kings were playing the
Clippers the other day the winner won
176 to 175. that doesn't even make any
sense to have a score like that right so
I think that's hurting the MBA product
do you think Ai and Predictive Analytics
is taking the emotion fun complete game
that Pride the shutout concept out of
MLB do you think AI is kind of getting
people to say well we're gonna have
three different pitchers today you're
gonna pitch three Innings you're gonna
push three things so but that's that's
kind of cool to get that but dude it's I
don't like that as a fan so you think
these guys are no longer thinking about
what fills up the seats and what gets
people to watch season baseball is that
a concern of yours
I I think you I think you're dead on uh
Pat um listen let's start with the NBA
so you gotta understand when I came up
with the Red Sox uh across the street I
got to go over and watch Larry Bird and
I got to watch uh Mikhail and Danny
Ainge and uh bam yeah some some you're
talking about your Parish you're gonna
be straight trash talkers right and uh
Red's there doing his thing and on
parquet floor so I I was I was lucky you
know enjoy I I actually did a little BS
show uh I think it was called the Rocket
report and I had I interviewed Michael
uh Jordan and uh I was just with Michael
not too long ago in in his course and uh
I've just smiled and laugh about it that
we're so young and but what I'm saying
is you're exactly right it seems like in
the NBA I mean if you give an NBA player
two feet
you know I'm guarding you from two feet
you're making that shot every time and
and I've heard the stories too they go
down and uh you got your 32 yeah I got
my 28 let's play defense the last five
minutes see who wins but the scores are
that that's you know that's why the
scores are well over 100 and doing
things there's just I mean other than
the playoffs like in baseball I preached
it's great that you guys can slug but
when you get to the playoffs pitching
and defense is going to win for you it's
no difference having a great defense in
the NFL
but if I'm if if I'm giving you this
distance from where we sit right here
Pat I mean you're scoring you're you're
gonna you're gonna score 50. and uh
so again I I don't watch a lot of the
NBA I watch when I know my friends in
the NBA are playing I watch them because
we have the same conversation you know
about what's going on have the same
conversation with my
30 PGA buddies is you know and some of
them are bitching a moaning that I'm in
not in the top 30 and they're pissed off
so well you play better and we talked
about early you know do something about
that and play better is what you got to
do so
um the changes in Major League Baseball
you hit it dead on um there's a bunch of
old school coaches uh in these camps and
I'm going to experience it tomorrow and
I'll see some of them and they'll they
they tell me you know like I said when I
was on the mound the seventh inning and
here comes the pitching coach or the
manager I got the ball tucked under my
armpit
and when he gets them out I said what
the hell are you doing out here get your
ass back in the Dugout I'm I'm gonna
finish this game or I'm going to eat as
many outs right now as I can we talked
about it earlier
and um there's only three or four maybe
a shirt sir uh there's a few there's a
few Verlander he'll stretch it out now
he's got a got a new elbow uh he's been
stretching it out and doing his thing
and um there's a handful of those guys
but you're right uh I I won't mention
the name but I was in I was in a locker
room during the game Talking to actually
a couple of the analytic guys the
picture the pitch that came out after
five innings he was done he was one in
the game three to one
he saw me you know you knew I was there
to watch too and he came in like he was
exhausted after five innings rips his
jersey often kind of throws it in the
laundry basket on the floor and I was
talking I said hold on a minute guys I
go what are you doing
oh I'm done I'm done Mr Clemens I'm done
I said yeah you want five innings I said
pick that [__] up there's no way it's
dirty and hang it back in your locker
there's no way there's no way yeah pick
that [__] up yeah and he started to I go
no I'm just kidding I wasn't but I said
no I'm just messing with you so
but uh yeah so I mean they're they're
doing some things where they call them
openers you know they're bringing in the
the long man first and then they're
going that way too so I I get that you
protect they protect they they watch me
early in my 20s uh still at about 115
120 pitches when I got in my 40s they
kept the Naomi in August because we were
going to the playoffs so they wanted me
fresh in October uh a lot of times if I
was the game one or game seven I was
always game three swing because that's a
big momentum do you go down two a lot of
times I was pitching where we were down
0-2 and
I couldn't have a hiccup when I went out
there we this was you know a must win is
a must win one of the biggest ones was
game three in 2001 when President Bush
came out throughout the first pitch
through a perfect strike and uh he
actually came in with his bulletproof
vest in New York we're playing the um
the uh Arizona Diamondbacks and we're
down two nothing and Mr Steinbrenner had
brought back all the all the police
officers and firefighters and people
that lost their loved ones I I it was it
was probably one of the the most
emotional games I had to pitch because
when I busted out of the locker room in
old Yankee Stadium
I turn right and go about 20 yards to go
to the weight room to do my cuff work
and get loose I don't like running in
front of the fans and stuff I'll get on
a treadmill and get all my priests so
when I go out there I'm hot and here we
go
and I busted out of the clubhouse door
and like I had some men and women some
firemen just hugging me and I was like
this is a month after 9 11 not a year
right so I was supposed to pitch that so
and I'll tell you guys this one on the
topic and I'm thinking about it
I played 24 years I tell people I
consider myself a great team player
um
it pales to the trip that I did so I was
supposed to pitch 99 11. I was a New
York Yankee going against my former team
the Red Sox or everybody and their
mother were in town it's going for my
20th win
I usually try and sleep to about 8 30 on
on game day we get we get in about one
after night game order from the the
Yankee Stadium
my buddy was only two floors we got an
overlooked floor that upstairs I put
Turf in that you can kind of look out
City real pretty eight miles nine miles
during World Trade
banging my door down about eight eight
oh five
and I'm like man what's up something
happened to World Trade so out our bay
window up there on the 25th floor I'd
always see
um four-seat airplanes going down the
Hudson so I thought it was a mishap with
one of the planes that go down tour the
Statue of Liberty he goes no it's bigger
than that so we run up
we could hear and fill the second plane
go back down turn turn on the tube see
all hell is breaking loose Dorman's at
my places you guys need to they're going
to shut down Bridges you need to get out
and get out of here
so we went to my buddy's place we loaded
everybody up my wife was there had a
bunch of girlfriends there we had other
friends we called people were all in
town to watch my 20th
and we and we busted out of there fast
forward we all know what happened how
what happened Our Lives and um how our
world changed General Myers our
four-star general at the time went to
high school with my agents
he he called and said would rock it go
to the Middle East to see our men and
women and I said call Drew Carey the
comedian Drew went with us uh told some
jokes seven days a booklet about the
size of my iPhone cover uh
uh military time
um
we lost one person when we were over
there it's really the only time I saw
Jerry Myers get up and get upset and
they dressed him down until the media
knew that we're we went into Afghanistan
to a base they just bombed
but anyway uh I met uh you know again so
if anybody I had five uncles that served
I lost my oldest brother he served in
Vietnam
and so anytime just like I I let off
with this speech in front of the guys
because the Phillies actually have one
or two guys that had uh uh served and
now they're trying to pick up their
baseball career I mean back in the day
Ted Williams and all these guys
um there's a normal thing back then but
yeah World War II yeah yeah uh uh um and
uh so anyway it was it was an
unbelievable trip
um I saw uh you know people that again
make me feel comfortable on Center Stage
in front of 55 000 people to be able to
do my job uh that night that President
Bush threw out that first pitch there
was I was in a bullpen with Mel
Stoudemire pigeon coach we turned around
with the Silhouettes you could see about
14 15 uh uh Sharpshooters on top of the
stadium and it was just and it lit up
like a Christmas tree he threw a
beautiful strike
the two stories you guys probably you
may have heard them already I'll tell
you the the two funny things I'll
regress here in a minute but
um
uh I I knew we were really close with
41. I knew 43 but not as well as I did
we even called him Gambia that's why he
called a grandkids campy anytime I went
to Kenny bunkport we got to throw
horseshoes I got a damn horseshoe pit in
my house because of him he sent over a
30 page fax on how to mix the clay with
the sand I mean he's serious about his
HW yeah he's serious
uh so
[Music]
um
uh 43
it's got the bulletproof vest under his
deal he wants to throw I said Miss
president you're going to have to
um
you're gonna have to go out the door go
to the right about 100 yards it's you
know the old Yankee Stadium you know
it's we got ghosts running around in
that place right and the the the the
batting cages all the way down there I
said Posada and Jeter and a couple of
guys probably down there doing their tea
work or whatever they're doing to get
ready so you'll see them he says great
so he goes down there
and uh those five or ten warm-up pitches
realize he can do it and then I wasn't
there this and this is the word I got
and I think it was on a documentary but
uh
he on his way out the door with all the
Secret Service he stops he sees Derek
shakes his hand he says Derek he goes uh
any pointers and uh Derek goes well miss
president yeah you can't throw from the
grass not the dirt you got to get up you
know where rock is at on the Rubber and
you gotta let it fly from there oh hell
I can handle that no problem I can do
that and he says anything else he goes
yeah he goes this is New York Mr
President and if you bounce it they will
boo you
uh and so he goes oh now I'm nervous
yeah so so he told that one my I'll go
back to my trip to the Middle East this
is what they all now
again I'm 6'4 they had two marines as my
bodyguards and they were both sick sick
I look like a no no offense to punters
and then but I look like a punter
standing next to these guys and uh uh so
they had me covered they said when we
could tell you when you jump in the
crowd and you're signing for all our
military guys I'm gonna whisper in here
you got two minutes to get to the chase
vehicle you got to get the chase vehicle
no problem
and they they both so when I got to uh
we actually flew over on Air Force two
then we got to Shannon Ireland we jumped
on they put me on a C-17 transport plane
with 25 of the baddest ass Marines
you've ever seen in your life
and these guys were getting on me
because I had a second suitcase I was
like one of you know a chick you know I
brought you know the clothes and I had a
sexy buddy Pack Light no they're on me
so I told them I'm pretty finicky about
what I eat plus I got to be careful with
seafood iodine in it man I look like
Rocky Balboa within a you know company
Mick and uh so
um uh but in the second suitcase I had
nothing but oatmeal Cliff bar I had I
had a powder and and granola and
everything because
um the two times I pitched for Team USA
jumping here getting long-winded on
y'all but uh playing for Team USA you
know I I I went over there and a couple
guys got food poisoning we had to send
them back and I found like a chef Boyard
for two weeks I found like a chef boy
already uh uh uh spaghetti and a Diet
Coke and I lived off that for seven days
eight days over there during during that
USA game
so I was being careful I'm not going to
go over and get sick and uh so I got
this all this stuff never bitching a
moan at me about it but I was teasing my
agent before I went I said hey I'm
taking this extra suitcase full of stuff
because I'm not going to get over there
and you know eat a camel or something
just messing funny isn't it funny so day
six we're at this princess thing in
Kuwait City
they cook two Lambs in the ground they
bring them out now I sat at a table with
some of the guys I've gotten to know I
didn't want to sit at the head table
with all their you know all their people
and uh everything that was going on but
General Myers is up there and everybody
else and they go you're up here you're
sitting front center with us Roger
Clemens head of the table so I'm looking
they got a interpreter and everything
and they set the first place and there's
pot there's a pita bread white rice and
I got a diet seven up and I'm saying
okay I'm gonna this is this go this is
it's gonna be my meal
out of nowhere don't you know they drop
a baby camel right baby
teeth everything right here
and I'm like you guys are messing now
I'm getting punked yeah I said no you
guys messing with me now
and I said I'm not getting that well my
agent had the guy they cut into it and
we're not eating the first cut into it
by the by the hump
okay it looked like Bernays was coming
out of it all right I'm like you got to
be kit and they dug around with these
big tongs and then put them next thing
you know he pulled out some meat that
looked like shredded pork and he puts a
softball size on my plate and
everybody's looking at me and these guys
are like they're all and Drew Carey's
look and I'm like and I pushed that
around my plate for like an hour an hour
I didn't care if we started a world war
or something you know you know so and
then and then uh uh uh Drew's girlfriend
at the time she she was dipping into my
stuff and I was like yeah y'all are
bitching you know getting on my ass for
bringing this and now you want my
opinion yeah you want my oatmeal
but anyway if anybody out there and you
guys know uh if you if you served or
anybody has served I freaking tip my hat
to you and say thank you uh it doesn't
go unnoticed uh we do a helping a hero
dealer
um we got uh we're building 100 homes
for our military men and women that
serve for us and and gave the ultimate
sacrifice and uh we got Johnny Morris
from Bass Pro he's he's playing a big
role in this Force so again I thank you
guys you know what a what a great story
by the way I watched that thing on um
I'm sure you saw Jeter's Captain
documentary I thought it was really good
and and you know there was a whole
section with you in it oh yeah the whole
911 George Bush that was interesting to
to watch that obviously you forget
Sports if you're a fan of the sports
like you know like like we are you know
you you look at it from our lens your
lens is different than our lens we're
watching you but when you saw that he
like I totally forgot can you show the
first pitch when he threw a uh uh
President Bush's first pitch right there
yeah take a look at this an absolute
perfect strike he's got a bulletproof
vest on underneath this jacket
let's hear the audio
[Applause]
[Music]
look at that
how great was that I'm out in the
bullpen right there and watching it that
Stadium lit up like a Christmas tree by
the way is that's uh that's one of the
greatest first pitches a celebrity is
thrown out again with all the pressure
like that 100 because the complete
opposite is the one that I just sent you
can you play the other one that shows
the top 10 worst uh tell me which one of
these is bad on your list let's hear the
audio
oh yeah I think I think one of the girls
was a gymnast and did like part well or
something else so this is uh this is
this is who Carlos yeah let's see who it
is yeah all right let's see how Carlton
watch it that's it you stick to running
but how does that happen you're the
greatest athlete
who else oh this is this is a good one
here I know what's happening here oh
beautiful pitch
[Music]
he threw him out this is gonna end there
MJ MJ yeah no MJ
[Music]
got the Cubbies
by the way you would have thought
Michael would have thrown like a perfect
you know or play baseball
but it was aggressive you know so that's
better than throwing a grounder
come on yeah here we go
all of a sudden it's show time oh Lefty
that's right
jeez all right you wanna catch it yeah
all right at least caught it
uh this is the one this is Nolan Ryan
this still might have been 85 miles an
hour
[Laughter]
and when he was 16 what is you Nolan oh
man I've been outside you didn't see
that one no that's a normal picture
Nolan he pitched inside a lot he just
brushing him off he knew exactly where
he was going with that
there's there's a first pitch somewhere
that absolutely yeah
57 50. so they don't want this album to
come out oh man that's a little splitter
right there you found something that
I've not seen before
[Music]
the point guard
oh here you go this is the one
[Music]
just embarrassing can you go back to
George W bushes by the way
by the way this moment right here
this was you know I'm all about
presidential approval ratings
uh this was the highest presidential
approval ratings I think we've had in
that moment right there in
I don't know
40 50 60 years uh you know right now
we're sort of hovering you're lucky
these days if you get to 50 whether it's
buying whether it's Trump yeah even
Obama was struggling to get to 50. he
was at 80 at this time it's pretty wild
to think about eighty percent we had him
at an event I I had him at the same
event that we had the late Kobe Bryant
at and when I announced hey and the
speakers at this event will be President
George Bush silent because some people
were not wanting to see him some people
were very happy but it was 50 50. I said
Kobe everybody for that they lost their
mind so Kobe President Bush comes we we
do the event
there's six thousand people there 6200
and we have a great conversation in the
back and then afterwards he's doing
photo op with 100 people that qualify to
do the pictures and I'm standing there
the entire time because I just want to
hear what people are going to say
and people would say things like let me
tell you I saw you as this and when you
were president I thought you were this
and I thought you were that but the
message you gave today because he just
opened up he says let me tell you what I
did I used to do this I had a bad habit
of doing this I had a bad habit of doing
this
the way he spoke that day everybody fell
in love with the guy that day the way he
spoke President Bush so it's interesting
that you're saying how one day they love
you next day they hate you next day they
miss you the next day they hate you you
have to be patient because if you're
loved today take your time someone's
gonna hate you in about a couple months
and if they hate you today be patient
trust me there's love around the corner
as well this whole concept about how you
deal with love-hate relationship how did
you handle that as a player because
that's that's got to be something you
experienced well I played with two most
historic teams you know I consider
myself really lucky you know being
drafted by the Red Sox at the University
of Texas you know so I mean the Rangers
and Astros are following me so close to
Texas you know again I I got to go back
to when I was in high school I was the
third best pitcher on the team I had two
I I took classes early so I could
graduate at 17.
um but when there were two other guys
are riding Lefty back in the 80s that
threw over 90 miles an hour which was
you know rare the scouts are coming to
watch him now we got in the playoffs a
couple times I was a better defensive
end than I was probably a pitcher first
baseman and uh really yeah I was six two
I was still you know baby fat you know I
was young Roger your hands are massive
hands yeah yeah I got my granddad
yeah is that a benefit for a pitcher or
is that for that split finger it is
yeah so the size of that ring but yeah
that's our national I'm wearing my
national championship ring more and I do
uh just because
um yeah it got start it really happened
for me at the University again
um you know jumping around I had three
wonderful coaches coming up you know I
lost my pops my high school coach
um great great coach better teacher of
the game and life lessons then I go and
I get to play for Wayne Graham one of
the winningest coaches in college
baseball turn the University of rice
program around
great coach better teacher to game
baseball lifer and um
he watched me grow and mature that
you're pop over to Texas
play for the winningest coach at that
time uh Cliff Gustafson and um Gus the
same thing great coach uh better man and
teacher of what we are doing life
lessons my boys go to University of
Texas they play for their winningest
coach in baseball Augie guerrito who
since since passed Augie was Augie was
gave them some great life lessons
so
again that's where I came from I I was
the third best pitcher I tell the kids
nobody but I threw strikes and I had a
little Bugs Bunny curveball so when
those older guys everybody came to see
him they didn't went to bed they [__]
the bed coach would bring me in the game
because I threw strikes coach always
said after you know I got I I made it a
couple years in the big leagues he said
you know that kid I could bring him in
turn the lights out in the stadium he
could throw strikes
so then when I got to Texas we didn't
there was no baseball lifting stuff we
lifted with the football guys so my legs
got strong I grew two inches fastball
started jumping next thing you know I
mean the same reason why I went to Texas
on scholarship mom didn't have the money
so I was Paving my way and she wanted me
to stay in school when I got drafted
after my freshman year
um the Scout said you know if he didn't
sign right now he probably never get
another chance my mom basically told him
and I was in my room crying for two days
she's kicked the scout out of the house
and he's going to school I want him to
get his education
so
that's kind of how that's that's you
know that's kind of how my path you know
took place and then um Boston drafted me
I was like
Boston when I don't even know I'm sure
where Boston was you know and uh but my
mom the history we love history and
um
[Music]
she wrote me a poem about Fenway Park
and then when I got to Fenway
um you know the green monster the the
best was when they called me up uh I
don't think cell phones are there this
is 83 and I was watching the game I
think Dennis Eckersley and Palmer were
pitching but they bring me in I get in
the cab and at the airport and I've got
my face in a paper and the guy stops
cabbie stops and this brick I see this
brick building in the cab because here
you go kid I go cabby I'm a professional
ball player I'm going to Fenway Park I
said this is a looks like a warehouse
I see the brick only you know he goes
this is Fenway Park kid get get your ass
out of my head and I and I get out and
the team meets me and they bring me up
the tunnel and the tunnel right you know
on first base side where you see the
green monster
and then to go you know there uh and
jump forward
playing as long as I did both the two
older boys and I had Devin I had a
little 10-year break and then the other
boys are in their 20s now
um they were able to see me play long
enough when the boys make a comment it's
like pops you know you pitched right
where Lou Gehrig gave his Farewell speed
or you know they I played in the Bob
Hope turn up 20 years I had Yogi Bear as
my partner a couple times you know
having Yogi I mean the guy's got he's
got ten Rings was he funny as hell was
he oh yeah oh he played it up I told him
I said hey about third or fourth hole
all this media follows I want to get an
eight by ten of you and I I'm gonna I'm
gonna line my putt up I want you to
leaning over like you're reading it for
me but we're doing it seriously there
was it was funky and I kind of knew
which way it's going to break but I hear
we stage this photo
and people are everywhere and I out loud
I go Yogi what do you think which way
you know what which way this ball going
he goes
better you than me kid and he walked off
and it was a little yeah he was I always
told Yogi that uh the two catchers I
wish I would have thrown to were Yogi
and Johnny Bench and uh Yogi was why why
me I said because I see all the old
photos of you Yogi and you never could
squat down you you know I would get the
high strike for sure because you could
never Squat and uh I thought you were
for sure gonna say Mike Piazza like the
yeah I actually had we I did throw the
the mic it sucked
and I and I sucked it was in the
All-Star game I don't think I I got it
took me about six batters to get it out
was there any camaraderie at all or like
yeah yeah we were we were Pros you know
Mike Mike's Mike's a good guy man but I
mean everybody makes it such a big deal
but I had some battles with other guys
too by the way for the audience so maybe
doesn't follow it yeah just play the
clip because we got we got two of them
pick one of them whichever one you want
yeah this is one of them you and Mike
yeah oh yeah they're broken back and you
grab the bat and you threw it back at
them well no if I'd have thrown at him
I'd have got him
I I I threw it on down deck stroke
everybody and TV made it look close
and and they were saying oh you said it
was the ball well when you're 60 feet
away and the bat shatters for a piece of
the head and when the head first came
what do we know to be the head of bed
but when it first came towards me you
can see I went in a Fielding position
yeah I thought I thought it was a line
drive back at me
but there's there's a couple other guys
that wanted a piece of him before that
so yeah everyone talks about that you
threw the bat at him it's like no hold
on the bat almost hit me first yeah well
again
let's not make Rogers seem innocent here
Roger you were trying to get in his head
as well you were you were yeah no you
know you were showing toughness the the
98 mile an hour fastballs what I'm
trying to get in into his mind yeah when
I when he breaked uh when the bat broke
the first sphere you see I'm 54 feet
away once I release the ball and once
you see that coming at you that's why I
went in filming of course
by Fate it takes two hops and it's in my
lap and I take it and I don't even know
he's and he didn't know where the ball
was that's why he was jogging yeah and I
whistled that was epic there was a there
was a picture that on TV it looks like
it might be from us but it was it was
further than that and I said just give
me another ball there was a bunch of
stuff leading up to that that World
Series trying to make it it was he and I
were almost a bigger story than the
World Series yeah and I was really
pissed about that but we also had a
Scouting Report which was fine by me
because our guys in uh going to scout
report they said we're pitching him in
fastball's in and if you miss you miss
inside his jersey and it's okay with me
because he Mike's a great hitter he hit
every breaking ball that I think I threw
to him and so I had no problem just
trying to live in there and again it was
a game like similar when I face I talked
about Reggie Jackson somebody like
Piazza they're going to get your best
he's one of the obviously best players
in the league at the time and on the
Mets for sure and I was sitting at about
91-92 he stepped in I think all three
pitches and including the one that
shattered about about 98. Reggie [__]
is about at me in which I'll see him I
tell the story Banquets which he loves I
wanted to get to the big leagues face
Reggie and I was sitting at about 93
with you know most of the guys in Reggie
was hitting fourth and here we go I mean
I was like 97 98 to Reggie Reggie's like
what's what's going on I go you're
Reggie Jackson I mean come on yeah
you're gonna get you're going to get
everybody's best there's no days off for
guys like that I like what you said you
said in an interview you said uh you
know uh guys you question who's the
toughest hitter you face you obviously
gave the love to Reggie Jackson because
that's who you wanted to face off but
then you said you never had a problem
with home run hitters because even pool
holes he said you have one pitch every
time if you miss it it's over I'm gonna
get you right so you said something like
that and he said the guys you had a
problem with were more the contact the
contact like the Tony Gwen type of guy
so who were some of the guys if you say
contact who were some of the tough guys
man just uh you know in American League
a few teams they had guys that were they
just had great eye hand coordinates you
make a bastard pitch O2 and with
especially at Fenway Park there's no
foul Crown it'd be different pitching in
Oakland that's the most foul ground you
know so they would just they're good
enough I I tell them that guys in the
big leagues can put wood on a bullet
doesn't matter how hard you throw they
can they can spoil a really good pitch
so if I get an 11 pitch it bat with you
in the first inning now I'm not getting
to the ninth inning which I know that
sounds what we're just talking about
guys going for when I said nine people
are going nine nine innings uh
then I might only be an 18 pitcher it
happens again I'm only getting to the
seventh so I'm throwing my two seamer
which I call a bowling ball I threw a
heavy two seamer down in the zone I want
you to hit it what we call the kitty
litter if you ever look at the place in
front of Home Plate where they water it
down really good other home teams water
it down more and they put more uh dry
dirt on it because you hit it and that's
like hitting Kitty liters stops the ball
from getting through the infield and
then sometimes the guys will grow like
at Wrigley they'll grow that grass four
inches high it's like hitting out a U.S
open rough it's not getting through that
and your inches high if you're if you're
a if you're a ground ball pitcher I mean
that's six four three all day that's why
that's why they you know you can do that
but those guys
um now Tony Gwen's a whole different
animal I face Tony in an All-Star game
and I try to ask some of the guys hey I
know Tony because I watched Tony take
batting practice and he played around
the world with his Bat and the ball in
batting practice
his first two swings he would hit it
into the cage
that he was in next two down on the
chalk line and left next to in the Gap
center field right field come all the
way around to to pulling two homers down
the right field line that's crazy that's
how good he was with where the ball was
going so I thought the guys were messing
with me they go you're going to face
Tony Gwen throw him a throw him a 94
mile an hour fastball right down the
middle I go that's funny you guys want
him to take me deep
they go no if you pitch him away he's
going to hit a double that way Minnie's
going to pull you I'm telling you
thought right I got I got a photo on my
phone in the All-Star game he was my
first one I thought right down the
middle he swings right through it kind
of looking at me he can't believe it and
then you know he ended up flying out but
it was a guy exactly you know we we I we
had one we had a Tony Gwen it was Wade
Boggs Bugsy bogsy
Bugsy could hit with his eyes closed um
with the sunshine interesting swing yeah
just he he's just a he's just a flat out
hitter Paul molota was he was he was he
very handsy very good call yeah Larry
Walker did you ever pitch to Larry I I
may have I I met Larry at some golfing
events later and we never really talked
but I'm gonna say 24 years for sure I
probably faced him back will did you
ever pitch out back because I know you
exhibition game probably okay yeah baggy
so if we put Frank Thomas Juan Gonzalez
those guys well those are Al right so
you pitch with those guys yeah do you
have any stories with Juan or Frank or
just you know another yeah just good
hitters I mean you got to catch him on
the right day
Griff was tough Griff had some homes my
my story about Griff we're in All-Star
game together and I had the two older
boys they're little this is when
Nintendo was big up in Seattle you know
he'd get all Nintendo games he could get
so so so the boys down messing around
the lobby or whatever and they got on
the elevator they run to the room
we're getting ready to go over for uh
media day and they're all getting Dad we
just met Ken Griffey Jr because I go you
did yeah what's up he goes he said for
us to tell you that when you face him in
the second half to if if you throw in
some fastballs right down the middle
he'll give us all the Nintendo games I
go you stay away from here
the kid yeah I said you stay you stay
away from grip bad influence you gotta I
mean do Pat a favor here Pat's guy was
Juan Gonzalez was it not why
no he's dangerous you got any good
Gonzalez stories for Batman I'm pretty
sure I faced him with the Rangers a lot
yeah
um I just you know he was dangerous he's
a guy that you know you had to stay out
of his little hot spot because he just
just he's just so strong
um
uh uh boy oh I was thinking when you
brought up molotar
um Robin Yount so my rock my Robin yacht
story I'm like right off the campus so
I'm I got a little piss and vinegar and
you know feeling pretty good and we're
in Milwaukee and uh Ralph Hawks our
manager now Ralph you know uh older so
some of the scouting reports weren't on
par and
um you know I had a veteran staff Bruce
Hurst who gave my nickname to rocket
after I hirsty gave me that
um we had some veteran guys you know on
the pitching staff and uh so now I'm
facing Molitor I was getting out and
this Rob Robin Young comes up and I I
he's already won one MVP at shortstop
he's going to win another one in center
field right in American League and the
Scotland Resort said we're going to play
more pitch him away we're going to play
him away
we're up three nothing and I throw in I
throw him on about 96 on the outside
corner knee high
he hits it it goes by this year I can
hear it it sounds like it's bacon in a
it's barely miss me it lands second row
dead center field at Old Milwaukee that
that dude oh Bernie or whatever's going
down the slide in the damn below yeah
yeah all that's going on Homer 3-1
I was like pissed off I was like man
that was damn good I can't believe that
comes up next guy monitors on I walked
him he got a hit
5 1
7th inning I think I throw one
it's about at least a ball off the plate
it goes by this year
into the bleachers about third row
people going crazy they pull me out here
five five three
I'm in the tunnel it's old tunnel nasty
tunnel there and I'm and they didn't
have uh covers on the lights and I'm I'm
hitting it with my glove I'm busting
lights cussing and swearing F F this is
Robin F you're having yeah that's
[__] I was bullying um and and I got
a group of pictures follow me and I get
upstairs and I I get in the ice and this
is again no I don't think cell phones
are and you if you called the clubhouse
you had to go through the operator at
the main stadium and then she would Pat
you into the visiting Clubhouse
so I'm Eisen and the guys come up and
after I cooled off and hirsty looks at
me he goes
he goes Rock he goes uh let me tell you
something he goes a great game
he goes but uh because I said he ain't
that you know I must said he ain't that
effing good or something you know and
her hairsty and the guys are like first
of all that's robbing you out two things
uh he is that effing good and number two
is don't listen to Ralph's scouting
reports a little out of date
thanks for telling me that now yeah well
you know him and him Brett got three
thousand same season by the way
unbelievable it was kind of wild yeah
Casey and uh Milwaukee so now
again I'm icing phone rings in the
Clubhouse games over the guys are
shaking hands they're on their way up
and that's why she didn't pouching they
said you got a phone call with your
mother on the phone
so I'm calling the clubhouse I mean this
is weird she's never done this something
had to happen
I get on the phone hey honey great game
great game and uh this night she goes
hey before you get out of the Milwaukee
will you get Robin yow's autograph for
him because he owns he owns you my mom
she wanted me to get his autograph
because he owns me what a mom yeah
she goes yeah cause I know if I didn't
call you wouldn't get it but he's a
really he's a good player wow and he
owns you it's crazy by the way she liked
that was she oh yeah
National deal for uh Mother's Day and I
had tried and get back at her a couple
by the way I wanted I want to show you
guys a guy uh uh the first pitch we
haven't given him enough credit so do
you remember when you guys would do the
Red River classic oh gosh you know I
sponsored it we were the main sponsor in
2019 and I was the first pitch and I
want to brag about my first page so I
want you to jump
yeah you're there by the way watch this
here go ahead how did I know this this
is this is how I get picked up
of course
I had a good time with you guys what was
going on I don't know maybe we had like
50 people there from our guys we uh our
headquarters like 10 miles away by the
way beautiful Stadium yeah Frisco man
yeah we brought the kids it was fun I
love the city just throwing grounds I
think I had McConaughey playing short
and he Dives after both knees are
bleeding after the first hand said dude
this is a celebrity softball yeah you
ain't got it yeah he's laying out and I
got Marcus's Trail there I mean some
guys are hitting bullets man they didn't
realize it's a real like people show up
in this is at the beginning of the game
by the end of it there was people there
but people show up McConaughey was there
yeah all of them there's a bunch of them
I'm probably naming them uh correctly
but there's a bunch of guys up with
there Roger
so who was the greatest Oklahoma coach
what's his name the the coach of
Oklahoma everybody brags about
Switzer Barry Switzer
shout out to Bob yeah you hear this
Roger I want to ask you about like a
pinch me moment so you know you're
throwing all these names out there so we
we're I don't know if you've got a major
pinch remote for me I interviewed Vince
Vaughn one time randomly yeah like nice
I love Vince Vaughn are you kidding me
but you're throwing out names that
you've that you've met you interviewed
Michael Jordan you're hanging out with
Larry Bird Yogi Berra all the names of
names of names what's your greatest
Pinch Me moment that you're like I can't
I love doing this with you all right I
mean this is this is fun and and like I
said I should have kept a journal my mom
said to do it but if I'd kept him I'd
probably been a two-year player and out
had nothing to
a big in history obviously being in
Boston I met the Kennedys and uh
um
just just so many cool guys I mean you
know they meet you like I tell guys you
know they're like hey on the mound I go
that's my job I was brought up that way
I take it very seriously like I said I
changed uh you know the
you know when I did it again I jumping
around here with these questions but uh
my sisters always remind me that two
days my mom sat at the kitchen table
with her hand when our electricity got
turned off so come on guys so that's
again that's why chasmine you silver
million no no no no no no do your
homework okay I said you know it might
have happened to something for some but
you know I didn't have a car in high
school I ran with my backpack from my
high school to our our town home and uh
so uh but to be able to meet some of
these people and you know they see you
and hey man you're funny they see me
DJing I go this stuff I love to do I'm
pitch I love it but again it was about
you know about winning because I'm
wearing a city on my chest I want to
perform you guys come get a dog and take
right from work take you know get your
beer and a dog I want there's nothing
worse than driving home after I've laid
an egg or I get knocked out in the third
inning I hate it but again like I told
the guys the other day in the clubhouse
I won 200 games because I was on with my
heater split right I was on you had no
chance
the games that I got out of second and
third bases loaded and uh you know my
catchers are like you know after the
game like I have no idea how we did that
you know we won five to four but that's
what they pay you to do they pay you to
pitch I know going to bark when I wake
up I go through the lineup taking my
shower I go through the lineup you were
you guys prepare I mean this is fun for
me because you guys are bringing stuff
on me that I forgot about so it's it
makes it fun for me now
I wash my hair I'm going through the
lineup I know when I get to the stadium
in that game I'm going to have second
third and one out somewhere in that game
I'm gonna have to get out of it to win
the game and uh so it's your mindset I
go through progressions like I said uh
physically I got you all the laps I ran
on backfields that nobody saw all the
Fielding I told the guys again in the
clubhouse I'll tell you guys I said you
know what your strengths are you polish
those but you freaking know what your
weaknesses are and just like in other
games I know what you do best I'm gonna
try and I'm gonna take that away from
you at the plate immediately
especially when I pitch inside I don't
pitch inside to hit guys I pitch inside
to make a 17 inch plate a 24 inch plate
I tell the pitchers that pitch inside
late it does nothing for you they're
going to climb right back on the plate I
pitch in early so when the guys are
still [__] around on the bench
spitting sunflower seeds the first
boom strike everybody talks about it
second Pitch boom inside light him up a
little bit everybody on the bench goes
oh oh [__] here we go here we go we got
a game so now you get guys attention and
and and you do your do your thing that
way but
I've met so many cool people I mean
that's the best Michael Jordan story
what's your best Michael Jordan story uh
well MJ Gamble's with a good friend of
mine and it's it's crazy it's crazy what
they do he's super competitive I got to
go down and play Grove 23 a couple weeks
ago he was there he kind of hit me from
behind and uh
uh I I actually myself and erlacker won
his last year of his tournament at um
at Shadow Creek uh I think we beat uh
what then was Bruce Jenner
and and and Penny Hardaway and wow and
these are legends but Bruce Bruce slash
Caitlyn they uh he he she hits the ball
far and uh I just said you know if if if
we play again and she's hitting from the
lady Steve we got no chance
because she because Caitlyn's a good
player too and uh but anyway nice guy
and uh uh but we uh yeah we uh we we got
after him pretty good and won that
tournament and uh but you know just
watching Michael play
um I thought it was really cool when he
was trying to play baseball I think you
know you know we we were we were teasing
them that somebody like that you know if
they got close to facing one of us in
the majors whether it be a devastating
breaking ball or a uh you know a 95 you
know he got the double A and uh we had a
little thing says uh he'd be writing
home to Mom says Dear Mom just saw my
first big league breaking ball P.S be
home soon
but did he have any chance of ever
making it to the majors it wasn't even
no Tebow probably had uh maybe a a
little Edge because just being a
competitive athlete like he is but it's
it's a different deal man it'd be like
you know trying to trying to backpedal
on a fast break with Michael coming at
you you got no chance yeah and uh so
when you hear LeBron saying I may play
for the cowboys stuff like that you
think it's the same thing what do you
think LeBron is a different thing he
could actually be a receiver
uh no yeah okay same thought yeah those
guys when if you ever I mean even in
college when you're on the sidelines and
you see a guy coming around and he he's
got the he's got eight yards to get a
first down you see it and uh the Gap
closes in two yards I mean it's crazy
how I mean again the biggest game we had
this past year Alabama came into Austin
and uh first time I met sarc I mean he's
been the man but it was really cool he
said hello to all of his coaches and
then he came down he saw me and gave me
a hug and he was he's a huge Red Sox guy
and uh but uh to see I guess I guess the
question will be to follow it so so what
do you say about guys like Brian Jordan
Dion bold those three guys because they
played they they they they played it'd
be like you know it'd be like the guys
that are trying to go on the buy.com
tour and golf too I mean it's it's a
different level there I played with guys
in our top 10 at the time uh in the 80s
and 90s even and there's a difference
between the 11th ranked player in the
world and the top five there's a
difference in the in what they're doing
now it might be the mental part of it
like I was alluding to earlier
physically I got you you know I'm on a
backfield I know my Fielding isn't great
but I got guys hitting me fungos while
everybody else is leaving the the
stadium and I'm taking 75 comebackers
and throwing them in Whistling the third
doing whatever and then I'd be coming
above average Fielder so when we get the
playoff time somebody's going to lay
down a bunt in a crucial spot I got to
get my ass on it and get the guy third
I'm ready for that and the second phase
is the mental part of game which I think
is the biggest thing mentally I'm
[__] going to kill you I got you okay
you you believe that and you know 100
100 if you make eye contact I want you
to make eye contact with me it come into
play but that's just the old school guys
you know where I learned like I said the
Drysdale Don Drysdale interview
what does the eye contact do to the
people I'm just I I'm just eyeballing
him just a little bit and uh and just
trying to stay locked in really and then
and then after that once he stands in
the Box I don't care if it's a rookie or
Albert Pujols I'm not really I I know
where your hot spots are but I'm not
you know I'm not focused on that I'm
focused on what I'm doing yeah and then
emotions come into play now in 24 years
I showed my backside a few times but I
care that's what I said you know I got
that from my mom I care about my work uh
you know everybody started doing this
with their gloves right where they're
hiding sometimes I got in a little
argument a couple guys and a few uh uh
what's my t-shirts say I love Jesus but
I do I do swear a little uh so I would
put my glove up and uh uh uh you know
it's a high desert but but that was
causing my mom like we're on national TV
and I got a little swearing contest with
some guy and after the game mom called
again she says honey can you can you you
know your your your brothers and sisters
are watching can you put your glove up
front of your face so that's I think
that's where it all started to come from
and uh it's good that she's not saying
don't do it yeah just cover it up yeah
yeah just cover it up yeah so she she
was uh she you know she was I mean I had
to pitch the night we lost her I was in
Austin she passed away in Austin and I
had to pitch that night and I knew she
would want me to pitch a tribute to mom
her favorite movie was Field of Dreams
so when I went to Louisville Slugger I
was able to uh obtain a Shoeless Joe bat
from that movie and
um uh so yeah that was pretty cool I
mean it was uh it was part of but anyway
that's the transitions I go through and
emotions I'll play on emotions Grandma
being sick mom passing to try and
elevate my game a little bit Yeah whose
favorite movie was filtered news it was
your mom my mom yeah I gotta tell you if
you
I love the Field of Dreams Kevin Costner
and all those movies it was even Robin
Hood back in the day dances wolves but
if you don't cry
when at the end of the movie He plays
catch with his dad yeah who comes back
to life I mean like you've got nothing
like big time by the way best baseball
movies ever what do you I mean you got
Major League you got the sand lot you've
got Field of Dreams uh the natural Money
Ball even you know you've interviewed
Billy Bean rookie multiple times I love
Moneyball 42 recently Jackie Robinson
what was it Major League what was the
best line I'm trying to think because
now they're running together but
um
Robert wall who Robert uh considers him
I I did was the agent right he's my
Hollywood agent so I was on our list
like three times arless was my uh arless
was my guy for um we I played I played
like a old Christy Madison 19 uh 16.
Philadelphia A's whatever it was but uh
Robert was in there with me and it was
only a baseball scene with Tommy Lee
Jones called Cobb yeah and uh kind of
dark but uh it was the only baseball
season but uh uh um what was it uh we're
talking about the movie so it's a shower
scene the manager is screaming at the
guys get everybody in the shower get
dressed you got a minute to get into an
accountant and they were all in the
shower Roberts there as the pitching
coach and and the managers airing their
ass out he goes so whatever his name was
the pitching coach he goes so and so
what's our record
he goes uh to the manager he goes eight
and sixteen coach he goes 8 and 16. he
goes how the hell did we win a game
Major League yeah
so that that was that coach by the way
where he's just like every time I come
in here you're bitching about something
it's an arm thing it's got to be well
that's where I got my jersey
lollygaggers
that's right
I have a I have a jersey when I DJ
sometimes so yeah is that your favorite
would you say that's it yeah probably
probably I mean there's no there's some
good ones yeah I got a couple other
questions here for you they're filming
that in Milwaukee by the way the one on
the top right supposed to look like
Cleveland yeah sure they did that in
Milwaukee County Stadium speaking of
Milwaukee just late breaking news Robin
Yount is on the phone here he wants to
have a conversation with you but but you
know you said something you said when
you're up there you know physically I
got you mentally I'm locked in just make
eye contact I got it then it's emotional
like those three sometimes my back
grabbed it all that stuff you're talking
about physical mental emotional fine
Derek Jeter said something he says Roger
Clemens is in another world when he's
pitching he's there but he's not there
what is what does he mean by that Derek
has to holler at me twice to step off
the mound you know when there's
something going on uh he has to get my
attention twice did you play with DJ I
mean obviously everybody knows um he's
probably a better person than he is
baseball player and that's saying a lot
and
um uh teammate
um uh one of the best
um I think that when I competed against
him uh he knew he was going to get my
best uh at that time and
um then he found out when we became
teammates they put a little joke on me
when I came over uh my first live BP at
in Tampa at the stadium I think it was G
knoblock and and Tino and they all
climbed in the cage with full catcher's
gear on
Jeep said you hit me all the time I said
you crowd the plate your hands are over
I said most of the time I hit you it was
a strike you know so we we went at it
that way but uh uh have you seen the
movie Legends a bag of rants I have okay
so you know how he says you know like
there's a scene where everybody's around
he's about to hit the shot and will is
trying to get him to say the audience
disappears did you really get to a point
where the audience disappeared or no I I
tell this all the time pat you hit it
right on the head it's it I think it's
the same scene where the Fairway looks
like it just exactly yeah and and that's
what and and that's where that's where
you get to
um uh the young pitching coach of the
Phillies we just talked the other day
and he was taking notes and and and I
got on some stuff that nobody would
think about like at Fenway Park and at
Yankee Stadium I had the the ground crew
Mo their last Mo job right down Broadway
and the mowers about the width of a
pitcher's rubber
and so when I'm standing on the mound I
have it's like a bowler I have a lane
yeah where I'm going to and if I keep
missing a ball or two off here some of
these guys start jacking with their arm
angle all you got to do is move over one
inch it's like a go if I'm hitting a
slice and I'm out there gambling against
you and and I gotta I'm gonna go to the
right side of the Tee Box and I'm gonna
hit that I'll fix it on the Range in an
hour instead of next thing you know I'll
owe you a grand at the end of the round
you know so
that's the same thing with that the the
the the the the sometimes the turf has
the the seam that uh you know is going
right down Broadway so it's just a great
vision City so now so now you're not
thinking about oh am I going to do good
or bad against it you're locked in on
what you're doing how do you get there
though how do you how do you get what do
you tell okay so for example like you
know good ones can do it man I know that
but there's a routine like you know
you're a public speaker first time you
speak you're scared shitless you're like
oh my God what if I scroll what are you
breathing so how do you control not all
of a sudden do you look at them do you
not make eye contact you shouldn't just
look at somebody else act like you're
looking but you're not so you know so
but after the two minutes you're rolling
no question about it so but you're but a
great speaker when he's going up there
he has a routine he's telling himself
something right you're about to go to
the mound what are you telling yourself
are you telling yourself are you
listening like when I uh had Kobe Kobe
talked about how he's listening to
certain music song you know Friday the
13th he will listen to that song to get
himself he had a psychological he would
get into the zone was there a routine
was there a song was there a book was
there a quote was there an affirmation
were you telling yourself something you
got this Roger just remember when you
were 14 it's the Love of the Game what
are you feeding yourself before you go
up there what they say about your your
your your your
um pressure you will find your
weaknesses okay and and that's why we
practice perfect that's why my Bullpen
sessions are locked in intense like I'm
doing a I'm doing a 12 minute bullpen in
between and I'm going to be starting
game three or it might be a Wednesday
afternoon business special yeah it might
be as simple as that not not but you
wouldn't consider a big game
I'm doing this and I got guys moving
over here or the lawn guy or the guy
doing this or I got somebody talking no
no no no stop because I want to be right
here my first three starts in spring
training where you're going one two
innings I can hear the popcorn vendor I
can see guys moving in The Dugout I can
hear my sister or something yelling for
me by the by my last two starts of
spring training it's just like that
movie I don't I don't hear anything I
see The Catcher And it's a game within a
game I've had like I said some wonderful
catchers in my career and I'll call them
out sometimes so my catchers like to
move a little bit more and catch balls
on their breastbone
and I tell them I have to call them out
and I go sit your ass still you're
moving am I moving rock yeah you're
moving too much because most umpires
when they get down they put their hand
on The Catcher And if he I got I I if
I'm painting a picture yeah and it's
just and he goes it's a ball
so I want you to sit still trust your
hands I'm going to get it to you a
professional player
really a double a player on to the big
league guy if you're catching me and
you're asking for a ball and I should be
able to get the ball within a a ball and
a half to where you want it
and not make those one or two mistakes
you know solo home runs are good three
run homers I I had the pitching coach
Bill Fisher who's passed went and spoke
at his funeral in Council Bluffs uh to
this day he still holds a record for 91
Innings without walking a guy
so his biggest deal with me when I
struck out 20 set the Major League
record I didn't even know there was a
strikeout record I was just going
through that game almost missed the game
there's a story behind that almost
missed the damn game and got scratched
punch out 20.
he comes over everybody's gone my wife's
waiting in the park and I just got done
ice and get my street clothes on and he
called me smokey after Smokey Joe wood
he was old school fish was he had Tom
Seaver that's the reason why Tom was
with us he had Seaver when he was with
the Reds
fish says Smokey he goes two things he
goes uh and I didn't know at the time he
said you know congratulations on the
record you know you beat these three
guys they had 19 you do 20 blah blah
blah he said uh really proud of you
throwing that rate of speed he goes but
guess what he goes you didn't walk a
single batter
and I go that's pretty cool fish coming
from you that means a lot for you see he
took two steps turns back around because
I almost missed the game I got I got
stuck in traffic and it was late crazy
and it was bad I mean I felt like a
rookie or going through the clubhouse
door everybody's looking at me like are
you nuts so he he stepped traffic he
walked away excuse me I know it's not
the Celtics were playing a playoff game
and there was a concert going on I I was
getting ready to run to the stadium but
I'll finish he takes two steps because I
almost missed again he takes two steps
away if he comes back and goes Smokey
another thing he goes you get to the
damn ballpark anytime you want and I go
fish I will never be that I was
embarrassing I said it was it was I mean
I I was sitting and I could see the
Citgo sign I was a mile away had my
boots and jeans on the golf shirt whites
with him we just had the one car we're
living in apartments you know
stuck in traffic I'm panicking starting
to sweat a little bit this game started
at 7 35 back then it's like 6 50. and
you know so I get out I pop trunk I say
slide over I'm gonna put my run take my
boots I'll put my running shoes on I'm
gonna run how far are you from it's a
mile it's a mile I'm gonna run to the
Stadium from here because we're moving a
Car Lane hi Roger Clemens
did you literally run no I I got in
started putting my things on my trunk so
so so the the motorcycle police officer
comes in thinks I'm broke down hits this
thing I turn he looks at me goes holy
[__] you know rock it he goes hey aren't
you on I go yeah I'm supposed
that is so cool you gotta get it Roger
you gotta get it no no you gotta win hey
Pat he parted that scene so cool be part
of the sea I jumped out in the parking
lot I ran in the locker room it's like 7
10. they've already got a long man in
the bullpen ready to go fish my pitching
coach goes into manager's office they
fixing to get my ass chewed out
sit down there and McNamara's the
manager Max said um we're scratching you
you're gonna now I gotta talk to the
media I'm about to and there ain't no
way I said [__] I'm getting dressed
I didn't take a no Finance I run out
dressed in a phone booth my pitching
coach is 60. he's never run you know
Fenway Park the home to the bullpen it's
a pretty good waste I thought he was
going to pass out we Sprint I get out
there I'm warming up I don't even throw
a strike I don't I'm bouncing the ball
he's on the phone he's talking to the
war he's like leave the long man out
there he ain't getting out of the first
inning he's all over the field I mean
I'm hitting I look like some of those
things the same you look like PVD this
is pretty good it's a softball yeah I
look like the other I looked like the
other descent out there
only peace and quiet I gets the anthem
finally I get the worst temp out of my
shoelaces untied bend over I mean I
remember like yesterday yeah I thought
my temple was going to fall out and I'm
like
and we get out there
freaking Restless I punch out 20 and
that was that same game talking about I
punch out 20. how do you lock into it
how do you lock into it just start you
know it just started going and and so
and that's why I told you I was ice and
fish said you get to the damn ballpark
anytime you want yeah so so no song you
don't have a song before you don't have
any of that stuff man I played I played
uh
late my career you know Toby Keith's a
good friend so not as good as you once
what but good once than there ever was
and shout out to my man Toby he's been
battling and uh
um uh man I did Linkin Park for those
guys you know it's different guys I meet
and you know I did some stuff with
Nickelback so Nickelback you know I just
I just I just kind of you know I got
friends like I said the other sports I
watch guys you know uh you know I watch
guys in football that I that I root for
and uh that I met that are really cool
guys and uh again it's it's kind of wild
you meet him off the field and you see
him for the first time then you see what
they do so so it's cool but I'm that way
with like like sitting right here with
you guys I mean it's it's this is cool I
mean I think it's uh you know I I see
the pictures in the studio and what you
guys do and uh uh my two younger ones uh
are are business oriented big time so
they're they're into it and not that my
two older ones aren't they they've got
uh they've got their priorities too so
I want you to see this like would you
have ever had a walkout like this now
obviously you're not a relief pitcher
but when you see this here and this
video goes viral on Twitter gets 11
million views I wonder what you think
about this press play I want the energy
I want all of it I mean it's just the
intensity of it have you seen this
before Roger or no press play
and now Timmy trumpet takes Center Stage
as Edwin Diaz gets ready to come in tell
me you've seen this before
watch this
the best walkout right now
the music the build up
Adam have you seen this oh my God she's
about to flip out
look at this
look at the energy in the place oh my
God
ready
here we go Timmy trumpet
[Music]
that's intense
now what makes it worth it
you got to get to save that's right
[Music]
I'm the starting pitcher right now icing
upstairs right now and I'm watching all
this I'm saying it's so great but let's
get a couple out
so
I'm just going to tell you right now
that's cool
and and all these clothes you have got
it from the the king Mariano Rivera when
when Mo comes in he's probably got the
coolest jog ever coming in from the
bullpen at Yankee Stadium find one of
those Mo will have his glove uh in his
throwing hand uh and all you see is that
42 coming out of the uh the bullpen yeah
the greatest closer Ever no doubt no
doubt no doubt by the way where did he
get it from he the he got it from Ricky
Vaughn the wild thing yeah your league
there it was Ricky Vaughn didn't have
that cutter
Ricky Vaughn early in his career looked
like some of these guys
too press the song Let's Hear It what is
it he usually puts his glove in his
right hand
again
yeah so I tell people there's had it
there's there's
there's two things for sure in life but
there's really three death taxes Mariano
Rivera he's gonna he's gonna close it
like that oh it's it's insane but by the
way earlier you talk about catch or
pitcher how much of the the the the
experts like the guys once you're like a
the best pitcher in the league you Randy
you know you got that Nolan Maddox uh
you know Kershaw all these guys how much
of it is you leading the catcher how
much of is the catcher leading you or
does it change based on the experience
of the catch I know you said I would
have loved to have Johnny Bench or Yogi
and all those guys I totally get that
but are you directing the catcher or is
the director a catcher directing you I
guess the the what I would want to know
is the split like I'm sure you're gonna
say there's part that you are part that
he is but is it 60 catcher 40 you is it
Adu 20 catcher what is that relationship
with the Catherine 80 20. Adu 880 80
20.80 but that 80 that amongst that 80
that catcher knows that 80.
and you noticed he was calling he was
calling his he wasn't waiting for the
catcher to call it he was he was calling
it from his wrist he he had one on I
don't know if he's gonna pitch with that
on but uh mine was all done with looks I
mean and like I said I had to be careful
if a guy got traded because they knew a
little bit about him
plus I would tell Jeet or and Adam
Everett who I was with the other day and
that I'm fixing to induce a ball coming
to you so heads up now Jeep would sneak
up the middle a little bit towards
second because as you know he had a
great backhand he had that famous jumper
that he looked really I mean that was
his patented you know his his his deal
and um but the catcher is super
important but uh Jorge would catch
Mariano and everybody knew especially if
you're Lefty he's throwing that cutter
Mo would break uh one or two bats every
outing you know closing the game and he
would throw that cutter so the hitters
you'd see the hitters sneak off just a
little bit when you didn't think he was
looking but Sato do his eye and he would
just follow him in further and uh
World Series with the Yankees is that
what it was yeah with that with that
team nucleus right there we had an
All-Star at every position yeah uh great
manager Joe Torrey uh uh uh great bench
coach and Don Zimmer had Zim in Boston
Zim was I mean baseball lifer
um did he get into it Pedro yeah
Pedro kind of gave me the Matador but uh
yeah it was I I was on the mountain he
was getting crazy and they knew on the
other side somebody was going to eat one
eventually and uh I just threw a high
fastball to Manny it was a strike these
days I think and all hell broke loose
but yeah we saw this ball-headed guy go
flying we thought it was David what's
the one right there that's one go back
there go back watch this this is a
strike
[Laughter]
look come on it's not even it's over the
inside corner come on okay these days
they call the high strikes
no uh
that is hilarious but I think I think
zimco's flying over here there he goes
yeah
oh my God you know 70 I go what are you
doing Sam Jesus
what's opposite about this go to the
other clip that I sent you the one with
I just texted you which one I'm talking
about I want to see his reaction to this
with the audio because the look is the
one I'm interested in to see what you
say about this so let's see if you find
it no
uh I sent it to you earlier you should
have it you should have it somewhere
here if not I can resend it to you but I
texted it to you if you look at the text
just go to text it's the second one I
sent you right there right right there
go to that one all right so this is you
against Estes I'm getting ready you
remember this yeah I'm trying to go deep
and watch this
I'm actually curious to know what you're
gonna say about this one here like what
you were thinking
he was actually trying to hit you
I don't know how you missed my big ass
es they know it's coming here's the
first pitch fastball it hits him
he threw it behind him
it went behind him I like what the guy
says at the end
he's upset that he didn't hit him
because he was trying to hit him
yeah I think the uh
we had a couple uh other their players
and looked out at us did not make any
movement see I'm not going anywhere
to be disappointed in that result he was
obviously trying to hit him and he
missed I'm 6'4 240. how do you how do
you miss me at that time so what what's
what's the I tried to stick my boots
so what are you thinking there when that
happens it's kind of like the tables
have turned now you're on the other side
yeah but I I play it's like in the
National League
um the guys would say I think the three
years I was in the National League and
they're like okay because he has to hit
two and you have to go to the plate
it's almost better because when you get
in a game that you have to clean up a
game because they've thrown at one of
your guys and you gotta clean it up down
the road uh it's even better in the
nationally because now instead of
throwing it one of my teammates they can
hit me so if you're gonna hit me
hopefully you put me out of the game
because if not then I I got the magic
bullet again so that's that's the I say
that's the ugly part of the game but
it's the old school part of the game
when I have a teammate that comes no
they really don't sit next to me on the
bench or come down the tunnel but when
they do I tell them hey you know what's
up I said you got a problem with this
guy and some very famous players I got a
problem with this guy Rock he's getting
his I go we'll take care of it later
so if the if it presents itself you you
clean the game up there's been times
where my teammates pitchers were
supposed to clean up a game and then it
fell to my gain so I I got to be the
shitty one uh you know but that's you
know you get respect from your teammates
and and uh you know like I said did you
hit them back or no no no he he missed
me and then they said that's it you had
your chance uh one of their uh uh who am
I thinking of
um
gosh who was the guy that's in the
bullpen for them I played golf with the
guy he he brought it up he's like no you
had your chance you missed him so that
was it so I actually got a little bit
closer to the plate and I think my knees
are in the strike zone and I thought he
was going to throw maybe away but he
threw it right in there strike three I
thought it was Roger with I was watching
a clip uh with uh what's his name uh
Stephen A Smith and he's talking about
how the hell do certain people not
belong to the Hall of Fame we have we
have to ask the question because you
can't do this without having a
conversation about that and the
controversy of it you uh I own I want to
say I don't know how many rookie cards
of yours I own I think I own 60 Barry
Bonds PSA 10 rookie cards right I own uh
you know some of the bigger Ted Williams
card Yogi Berra you know all those guys
and Babe Ruth PSA 8 1933 Gowdy's like a
million Auto card I want a lot of these
baseball cards I love baseball cards but
there's certain guys you're like dude
you mean this last Hall of Fame you got
what 65.2 I think was an number some
number like that you need to be at 75
that you know with that and you've
commented you said something very
important I think was like 10 years ago
uh where you said in our family we're
not even looking at the whole concept
with Hall of Fame anymore it's not you
know the first half of my career was
about you know a generational wealth
I've done that my family's taking care
of second half I wanted to win you did
that create your Champion your numbers
are incredible and there's a lot more
people who are critics and not even fans
of yours that would say this guy belongs
in a Hall of Fame what are your thoughts
you've spoken about this probably not
something you like talking about
regularly but what are your thoughts
about this whole there's plenty of these
guys that we feel belongs there what do
you have to say about what they're doing
right yeah well you said it Pat I mean
after year one when it became political
we we quit worrying about it each year
that comes you know writers would call
or people would call to say hey can I do
an interview and this I go guys I've
already made my blanket statement
there's nothing really to add I have
zero control over that and like you said
I probably get more uh all my public
opinion clearances I probably get more
people that that you know wish me and
say you said the only answer you say is
thank you I appreciate it yeah because
they look bottom line they looked at the
facts and we did it you know we weren't
about it the right way what we did was
we stopped not one now that I know of
but since three people from making money
off our last name and trying to and
trying to sell themselves on on that
fact and so um
again uh I can tell you when I um
General Myers all the guys wanted to
miss they called me after the all the
Congress stuff and said hey I had to sit
in that same seat it's not comfortable
they were going to try and trick you
there was no facts they had some guy
reading a doctor's report that the
doctor never even saw me I mean it was a
it was almost like a trap because of
what they were doing I think the wax I
called him wax head he was up there
sitting on a stack of phone books just
trying to preach to you and let you get
your story out and what things that
meant to you more than my dad like you
know even even uh that the health risk
of it when I got family heart issues in
our family and stuff that uh that uh
again I I need to write about it one
time because I want it to be a a if I uh
I told the family I wanted to be a great
book and I want to give credit where
credit's due but I'm gonna cut some guys
off at the knees too about some stuff
that's never really been out there or
like I told people if you can read past
the third grade uh you would have known
what was going on and uh I said I I like
Jerry Springer and I like watching this
[__] but it turned into a straight Jerry
Springer Show but again president uh
President Bush called me uh the support
that I had from people that know know us
and know us as people uh uh you know
that's the way it is but the Hall of
Fame is not going to change uh who I am
as a I tell people that's what I did for
a living is not who I am as a person but
I took it very seriously but it's not
going to change uh are you being in the
Halls not going to change it are you an
NFL guy or no did you did you follow the
NFL do you follow the product NFL or not
really I mean I root for the guys uh you
know okay yeah do you remember Sterling
sharp remember Sterling sharp Shannon I
know both of them so uh um
uh one on the golfs a little more who's
on TV now this uh Shannon right now is
on TV Shannon so it's Sterling's the
golfer yeah he does yeah yeah did you
did you see I hope I I gotta try to find
this man did you see the speech uh uh
Shannon gave at his Hall of Fame speech
and how he brought in his brother and
what he said about uh uh Sterling sharp
oh brother I mean I I'm out of okay oh
thank God I found it okay I want you to
see this and the reason why I want you
to see this I have a couple different
things uh where I would go for me uh on
you know just play this person and I'll
give my thoughts I want to kind of get
your commentary on thoughts on this
because you know what you've done with
your 24-year career of staying in the
league that is not easy to do but play
this clip and then
it's a tick tock click it's not even a
um
it's very emotional very emotional on
the angle he takes I had no idea where
he was going
if you can turn it on his brother this
is right right rewind is he older than
no story yeah okay so watch this
pray go ahead
267 man that's walk through this
this building to my left
that can honestly say this
I'm the only pro football player that's
in the Hall of Fame
and I'm the second best player in my own
family
watch this very emotional guys watch
[Applause]
[Music]
this is nothing you have to hear what it
says next
[Applause]
the Fate have dealt you're a different
hand there's no question there's
absolutely no question in my mind
we would have been the first Brothers
to be elected to the Hall of Fame
the 44 men and women that I thanked and
congratulated early for giving me and
bestowing this prestigious honest upon
me
all I do is ask
all I can do is ask in the most humblest
way I know how
is that the next time you go into that
room or you start making a list
look at Sterling Sharp's accomplishments
a seven year period of the guys that's
in the Hall of Fame at the receiver
position
and the guys that have the potential
be in this building that's all I ask I
don't say hey
just do that the next time you go in
that room
think about Sterling Sharp's number for
seven years that's all I ask
[Music]
[Applause]
managing expectations
so for me here's how I see this
uh we had Curt chilling here two months
ago okay you're seeing him give this
speech if you watch the whole speech
when he gives and you're seeing Sterling
is just like you know the the Terrell
Davis one time was crying and the
Broncos were playing like 13 years ago
and his tears were dropping do you
remember the running back of course and
you're like I've never seen anybody cry
like this before during the Super Bowl
it's an emotional moment
somebody in freaking Baseball Hall of
Fame needs to give a speech like this
and say there's there's a bunch of guys
now you hear the criticism saying you
know the Major League Baseball doesn't
allow Republicans in the Hall of Fame
because there's become political then
you can't make comments like that or
this and this and that hey you're you
went to a trump rally how dare you go to
Trump rally and you're doing this and
you're doing that Court chilling you've
been saying all this stuff there's a
list of names that you can talk about
the bagwells the Reigns The Hoffman are
Shilling to you the bonds to Martinez
musina Trammell Smith McGriff Kent
Walker Maguire Sheffield Wagner so
there's a lot of names right these are
guys that crush it I wasn't I was in the
army 1998.
and
Major League Baseball had just come off
the uh uh their strike I think they had
whatever the year was 96 or 94 97 I
don't know what the year was nobody was
watching baseball nobody was watching
baseball nobody was interested in the
product it was boring it was dying
stadiums were empty then all of a sudden
these two guys come up
and one's name is Mark McGuire the other
guy's name is Sammy Sosa and every night
when we would come back to the barracks
dude we would stay up till God knows
once we just wanted to see the you know
we just want to it's like what's a
freaking you know rock and roll they
revived baseball Oh's Sammy and Mark
McGuire billions of dollars MLB you owe
those two guys revived the flipping game
so here's where I take it
I watch football and I look at some of
these guys what they look like you know
I'm a guy that's uh tried primobolin I
did uh uh the trt for like five or six
weeks and uh clembuterol some of the
stuff that you know because I wanted to
be bodybuilder and you're kind of like
[__] I gotta get into Center you you
really find out what the bodybuilders
you're like oh [__] I can't do all that
stuff but trt you know you got these HGH
some of the stuff that Hollywood's doing
it football they don't really get tested
as much as some of the other leagues
these guys playing football by the way
if you're not on something and you're
getting hit by 350 I'm worried about
your neck I'm worried about your body
I'm worried about what you're doing so
to me it's not even about the
conversation about that there are guys
that gave their lives to this game that
entertained the hell out of fans like
myself and increased the product of MLB
that belong there but I feel like some
of the existing guys are playing
politics and some of them need to grab
their you know what and make a speech
and say hey man what are we gonna do
make an exception for these guys to get
in I played against these guys so I know
you can't say anything about it yourself
because you've already gave your message
and I'm not looking for you to have a
reaction to it all I'm saying is this is
my opinion these are my thoughts uh I
think uh the game if we were to look at
baseball in a 20-year period and we said
okay during that 20-year period no
problem take moguire out take Sosa out
take bonds out take Clemens out take
these guys out what the hell is baseball
take those products out who the hell is
coming to watch the game who's trying to
see the the temperament the mindset the
travel the sacrifice the nine months out
of there you're on the road you're
having kids you're going through all
this stuff take all that stuff out
nobody's coming to watch the
commissioner play they're coming to
watch you play right Michael made a
comment about this in the last dance
when they were talking about you know
they don't come to watch the GM play
they don't come to watch the owner play
they come to watch us play right he gave
a representation for the guys and
Michael wasn't a guy that made a lot of
money in the NBA when as in his contract
yes last year he made 33 million or
whatever the number is but it was never
the highest paid guy he set the tone for
everybody else afterwards absolutely but
it was also getting some perspective to
say these writers are voting you in who
the hell are you to vote a player in and
you ain't played what what opinion so to
me it's a little bit uh confusing I
watched I watch what they say the
speeches this guy's not and he doesn't
deserve this he doesn't deserve that uh
Hey writers you don't have a job without
these players if these guys weren't
playing putting their bodies through
what they're putting through you don't
have anybody to talk about you have a
job because they play so anyways that's
my uh that's my rant I'm not your room
with it I appreciate your passion I can
hear it in your voice
excuse me uh you know like Greg Maddox
told me he was voting for me mad dog
knows me as a person and knows the
person and I said I appreciate your vote
doggy but again it's not going to change
me as a person uh either way uh I heard
what I heard from you entertainment I
know we're entertainers but this was
still my uh like like you alluded to
earlier my first couple years has
changed the generational difference for
my family
um you know pay off my mom's bills but
you know get her a car and then it was
about winning championships
um the guys that know me you know I hear
some asinine comments from guys that
have no clue like I said if you could
read past the third grade you would you
would understand what what went down and
how it went down I'm never going to play
the victim but I am going to stop people
from using my name and and spreading
lies about me when they say it I do that
when people [__] on one of my teammates
and said hold up you you got him on a
bad day see like being you know signing
autographs I signed 50 the 50 first
person and I'm you know I'm an ass and
so you can't please everybody all the
time so true I'm not going to come off
phony because I'm trying to get you to
like me and uh you know this is who I am
this is how I was brought up and I let
the people uh you know like I said I I
did some inner city work in Baltimore
this this Baltimore Congressman made a
couple uh he made him after I was in his
office took 25 photos with his staff and
interns signed all these autographs and
he and he he was one that brought up you
silver silver spoon athlete I go hold up
a second you know I gave him the quick
rundown very Stern about my background I
said you're reading a piece of paper
you're coming out here in front of the
world and you're getting stats on me
five minutes from an intern
and that's what you go off of you didn't
you didn't take the time to learn about
me who I am as a person where I came
from or what what this might be or you
got some other dude spreading lies just
because he's trying to get my pocket so
that's what I should have done when I
went I should have just got my wallet
and laid it on the table I mean that's
what that's all it was about so
um I I have some great great friends
like Reggie Jackson that are in the hall
and they say stuff all the time uh again
I don't think it makes you uh for me
personally I don't think it makes you
hit a ball further I don't think it
makes you throw strikes being a control
pitcher I think it breaks you down and
hurts you a lot of these guys I think it
broke them down a little bit but uh you
know like I said I I'm not going to get
bitter over we just quit worrying about
it to come up day after day after day
and like you said I remember calling Jim
Rice my my former Red Sox and Jimmy got
in on his 10th try
so you either have the numbers to get in
or you don't they made him wait 10 years
because he pissed off a lot of reporters
I caught him and said hey Jim Ed I said
congratulations and everything I said
but let me ask them how did you get
better in 10 years did you go play
semi-proble and hit another 100 homers
I didn't I didn't see you to read about
it but so you know so you're either
you're either in uh the first one or
you're not so and I appreciate your
perspective because you're the player
but I give you the perspective from the
players I'm sorry the fans perspective
the fans perspective I'm a voter you
know we're voters we're not dude we
don't do what you guys I'm a business
guy I run businesses I busted my SLS 20
however many years in Insurance I've
done very well for myself and now we're
building a media company but from the
fans perspective when you're dealing
with a million things in your life
that's not healthy this guy's going
through this that guy's going through
this you're having girlfriend proms
you're having kid problems you're having
this you just want to sit there and just
watch a damn game and have everything
you were stressed out about be gone fans
are voting for you guys bro so it's a
different perspective for us yeah than
it is for you when you're like hey what
else can I do I've done my part I get it
but a fan is like no I followed this guy
for this many years that guy needs to be
in so it's a different perspective I get
that been and I appreciate you sharing
that one last question I got for you
it's going to be like why are you asking
this question as the last thing it's
just for my own shits and giggles
because I freaking followed this game
um Aaron Hank Aaron said something uh
one time about the whole you know the
whole uh you guys got the Cy Young you
shouldn't be the NBA when you won the
MVP
and he says look you know pitchers have
their own deal Cy Young we have MVP I'm
not changing my position they shouldn't
have given him the Cy Young and the MVP
at the same time you come back and you
said I have the quote somewhere here
where you said hey I'd love for him to
come here uh I wish he were still
playing I'd probably crack his head open
to show how show him how valuable I was
right it's kind of like what you said
that was the young rocket
rocket which is the Hank Aaron
about Pedro saying wake up Babe Ruth I'm
gonna hit him in the ass exactly so let
me quick story yeah so my oldest son is
Kobe Aaron Clemens he's named Aaron his
middle names after Hank Aaron so that
tells you all you need to know about the
young and piss and vinegar rocket
big respect from that of course I
thought your last question was going to
be about DJ no requests
let me let me just let me let me just
tell you if we got time how you put
things in perspective
and it goes along with that MVP award so
I win the MVP in the Cy Young my first I
gotta I'm a Red Sox I got to go to New
York City we call this the butter story
everybody loves it and it's true
go to New York
um pretty green I got DiMaggio mantle
Ted Williams I'm looking right as a who
who now Donnie Mattingly there I just
I'm the one you know Donnie finished
second in the in an MVP baseball now
this little suit now we're at the top
table and you're getting a cold piece of
chicken uncooked piece of steak a little
bitty baked potato and a dinner roll and
the dude comes by Straight Yankee fan
he's looking at me like and the look he
gave me I was like okay he's spit in my
food I'm there's no way
there's no way I mean I need it but I'm
gonna work on this dinner roll and maybe
this baked potato but he he throws me a
little cube of butter on the thing
and you know mustache strip his name's
got to be Tony for sure you know like
walks by doesn't again so I get through
that dinner right I only got one cube of
butter I needed one more but what the
hell first year up there
fast forward I win my second Cy Young
back to back back in the penguin suit
here we go now I'm popping my feeling
good I'm on Ted how you doing mick how
you doing hey Rocky yeah I'm first
feeling I'm feeling it talking away here
comes the [__] thing same guy same
friends Tony Super Mario looks like
Super Mario Bros he he goes by me and
and I'm like hold on guys hey I said
hold up man hold up minute he just gave
me one I need another cube of butter
that's all I'm looking for for my baked
potato you know just come on so I'm
talking I see him come on my guy and
here he comes again I I said dude stop I
said I've been trying to get you for 10
minutes my my stuff's getting cold up
here I said all I'm trying to do is get
another Cube up I said you know who I am
right he goes oh yeah I know who you are
I go good I said I'm trying to get some
butter he goes evidently you don't know
who I am I go I don't he goes I'm in
charge of the [__] butter
and I went and that's what everybody did
around
[Laughter]
he said I'm in charge of the damn Butter
and he walked off and saw that kind of
tells you but you keeps you in your in
your what a great story that keeps you
in check yeah what a great story so
there you go boys hey by the way you
never play for Rangers you played Astros
but was there any time that you almost
got close to playing football they were
just I thought I was going to get
drafted by him early in my career that
was it really so I played again I played
with the the history was there and then
going home to play we flipped the
football Town into a baseball you know
those three years and I I tease those
guys I have no idea how I wanted Cy
Young with Houston because we only had
three and a half hitters on the team I
don't you couldn't give up anything but
uh they were wonderful just uh again you
talk about the Hall of Fame I have more
guys that I uh owe a lot to being great
teammates that are not in the Hall
um and uh uh you know they I I I'd be
surprised if someone didn't say that
they didn't know where I stood when I
was their teammate so but again it was
my that's my upbringing well much love
too man I appreciate you for coming out
really enjoying it I had no idea what
direction we had some stuff but we had
no idea what direction was going to go
but two hours felt like five minutes bro
let's go literally two hours five
minutes this is cool and thanks for what
you guys do and what you guys did for us
and uh this is really cool anytime
brother thanks for coming out yeah
appreciate you hey come back out and
throw another softball
thank you everybody bye-bye bye bye
awesome